welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine
today my guest is Dr Susanna soberg Dr
Susanna soberg completed her doctoral
thesis work at the center of
inflammation and metabolism and the
center for physical activity research at
the University of Copenhagen in Denmark
her research has focused on how
deliberate cold exposure and deliberate
heat exposure can be used to enhance
human metabolism she is the first author
of a seminal study which discovered the
minimum thresholds for deliberate heat
and deliberate cold exposure for
increasing Brown fat thermogenesis which
is essentially a mode of increasing heat
production and Metabolism in the body
and for establishing actionable
protocols that can be used outside of
the laboratory to improve metabolism and
human health Dr sober's research was
published in the journal cell reports
metabolism in 2021 adding to a long and
important history of research focusing
on the role of cold and the role of heat
in altering various aspects of the
body's physiology including Hormone
Health metabolism and changes in
neurotransmitters such as dopamine and
epinephrine in fact today's discussion
with Dr soberg focuses on the role of
deliberate heat and deliberate cold
exposure on metabolism but it also
includes discussion of the effects of
cold and heat on things like
neurotransmitter production namely
dopamine and epinephrine and
norepinephrine the so-called
catecholamines which strongly impact
mood and Metabolism in addition Dr
soberg answers many common questions
about deliberate cold and deliberate
heat exposure including for instance the
difference between cold showers versus
cold immersion up to the neck versus
total body cold immersion including
whether or not going back and forth
between heat and cold changes
fundamentally the way that heat and cold
impact the metabolism hormones and
neurotransmitter production and we talk
about almost every single nuance and
variation on deliberate cold and
deliberate heat exposure protocols as it
relates to the underlying science in
particular how cold receptors at the
level of the skin are impacted versus
cold reception and perception at the
level of the brain and how all of that
impacts systems of the brain and body
relating to mental health physical
health and Performance Based on her
scientific research and academic
training as well as her understanding
and use of deliberate heat and
deliberate cold exposure protocols Dr
soberg is considered one of the world's
leading experts on these topics in fact
she is the author of a recent book
entitled winter swimming which is I have
to say a terrific book because it breaks
down chapter by chapter the different
aspects of deliberate heat and
deliberate cold into its various
constituent Parts including cold
acclimation the cold shock response
dangers and safeties of cold water
the impact of cold and impact of heat on
various aspects of human health as well
as specifics relating to sauna versus
Ice versus cold swimming showers Etc
it's a very thorough read and a very
easy and accessible read that if you are
interested in deliberate cold or
deliberate heat exposure or both will
allow you to embrace those protocols
with the greatest degree of confidence
that you're going to obtain the specific
endpoints that you're interested in and
to do so safely before we begin I'd like
to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
and consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Plunge
plunge makes what I believe is the most
versatile at-home self-cooling cold
plunge for deliberate cold exposure
talk numerous times on this podcast
about the many benefits of deliberate
cold exposure and indeed today's episode
is focused entirely on the benefits and
the science of deliberate cold exposure
plunge uses a powerful cooling
filtration and sanitation unit to give
you access to deliberate cold exposure
in clean water whenever you want as
we'll discuss during today's episode
with Dr Susanna soberg deliberate cold
exposure especially deliberate cold
exposure done up to the neck in water
can be used to achieve a number of
important endpoints related to mental
health physical health and performance
I've been using a plunge for more than
two years now I can tell you that it
makes it very easy to get your
deliberate cold exposure at home it
doesn't require much cleaning in fact
it's very easy to keep clean which is
essential you don't want bacteria and
other things growing in your cold plunge
basically everything about the plunge is
made easy so that anyone including
myself can gather deliberate cold
exposure on a regular basis at home if
you're interested in getting a plunge
you can go to plunge spell
p-l-u-n-ge.com huberman and get 100
fifty dollars off your cold plunge again
that's plunge.com huberman for 150 off
today's episode is also brought To Us by
Maui Nui venison which I can confidently
say is the most nutrient dense and
delicious red meat available Maui Nui
spent nearly a decade building a USDA
certified wild harvesting system to help
balance deer populations on the island
of Maui the solution they built turns
the proliferation of an invasive species
into a wide range of nutrients dense
products from butcher cuts and organ
Meats to bone broth and jerky their bone
broth has an unmatched 25 grams of
protein per 100 calories several guests
on this podcast who are experts in
nutrition have pointed to the value of
getting at least one gram of quality
protein per pound of body weight each
day with Maui Nui that's very easy to do
while eating delicious meals and getting
it from a sustainable Source if you
would like to try Maui Nui venison go to
Maui Nui venison.com huberman and get 20
off your first order again that's Maui
Nui venison.com huberman to get 20 off
today's episode is also brought To Us by
thesis thesis makes custom nootropics
and nootropics is not a word that I like
because it means smart drugs and the
brain doesn't have neural circuits for
being smart rather as neural circuits
for Focus neural circuits for task
switching neural circuits for creativity
and on and on thesis understands this
and Designs custom nootropics designed
to get your brain and body into a
specific state in order to do the mental
end or physical work that's important to
you such as creativity or Focus or
Clarity if you'd like to try thesis
nootropics you simply go to their
website you fill out a brief quiz and
they will design a custom starter pack
so that you can assess which things work
for you more or less well and then
they'll iterate with you over the course
of the next few weeks or months to come
up with the ideal nootropic kit for your
needs to get your own personalized your
tropic starter kit go online to
takethesis.com huberman you can take
that three-minute quiz and they'll send
you four different formulas to try in
your first month again that's
takethesis.com huberman and use the code
huberman at checkout to get 10 off your
first box I'm pleased to announce that I
will be hosting two live events in
September of 2023. the first live event
will take place in Toronto on September
12th the second live event will take
place in Chicago on September 28th both
Live Events will include a lecture and a
question and answer period and are
entitled The Brain body contract during
which I will discuss tools and science
related to mental health physical health
and performance I should mention that a
lot of that content will have absolutely
no overlap with content covered
previously on the huberman Lab podcast
or elsewhere if you're interested in
attending either or both of these events
please go to hubermanlab.com tour and
enter the code huberman to get early
access to tickets once again that's
hubermanlab.com tour and use the code
huberman to access tickets I hope to see
you there and now for my discussion with
Dr Susanna soberg Dr Susanna soberg
welcome
thank you so great to have you here I
feel like I should give a little bit of
the back story of how we got connected
which was that for many years I've been
interested in cold thermogenesis it was
the topic of my seniors thesis in
college and I've of course followed the
popularity of Wim Hof and we've had Dr
Craig Heller my colleague from biology
department at Stanford who works on cold
and its impact on physiology and sports
performance so for a long time I've been
interested in this area
but there's been a real uh lack of new
let's say high profile quality
scientific information in terms of how
for instance cold plunges and sauna how
that impacts human physiology I know
there's been some information out there
but it's been sort of scattered and then
a little over a year ago I see this
paper in cell reports medicine and was
immediately struck the first of all the
fact that it was in cell reports
medicine I've been on the cell press
editorial board for a long time now so
press journals are of course phenomenal
journals and the title and the content
of the paper was directly in line with
the sorts of practices that people are
very curious about and then are starting
to emerge things like sauna cold plunges
and there was your name first
on the author list and I reached out to
you through social media and we've done
a little bit of live content there
together and I've been tracking what
you've been doing in the world in terms
of your book and talking about the
results in your manuscript and talking
about the science and impact of
deliberate cold exposure and sauna and I
have to say that it's been a wonderful
and remarkable thing to see and you're
bringing so much quality information
about this area that for a long time I
think was kind of Niche and is now
becoming more and more mainstream so I'm
going to start off with a thank you for
being here and a thank you for the work
that you've done and I'm looking forward
to talking to you about it today so my
first question to get things started is
what is happening when we get into an
uncomfortably cold environment
so for instance if I'm really hot on a
hot day jumping into a cold pool feels
really good but if I'm already kind of
at room temperature I'm a little bit
chilly getting into that same
temperature of water doesn't feel so
good right there's a shock there so if
you could just walk us through what
happens when we get into uncomfortably
cold water whether or not it's by way of
shower or cold Plunge at the level of
our physiology and if you'd like our
psychology I think that's a good place
for us to start because I think it will
Orient people to their own experience if
they do that yeah and for those that
haven't done it might start to peel back
some of the the layers as to what the
underlying mechanisms of cold are yeah
thank you for that question it's really
good to just address what actually
happens in our physiology when we get
cold and you can get cold in many ways
so you can just head out for the one
that gives you the most potent stressor
which is submerging into cold water and
but you could also go in outside in the
cold wind that's also going to activate
your
um your sympathetic nervous system so
get all these neurotransmitter going in
your body and so your your
catecholamines
um let's just address that we are taking
a cold plunge for example so if you are
very hot for example
um before you go into the cold water
it's going to feel less it's going to
feel less stressful but the the
temperature difference from your skin to
the cold is definitely it's going to
give you a shock but your core
temperature is warmer and that's going
to feel a little bit better so that's
why when people go into a sauna for
example and go out in into the cold
water they they they can do it easily
easier them if they were called
beforehand could I just um ask you a few
questions so you you mentioned the
sympathetic nervous system which for um
people listening who aren't familiar
with that is that the branch of our
nervous system that's responsible for
creating accelerations and heart rate
um feelings of alertness it's
accompanied with stress and the stress
response but it's accompanied with
waking up in the morning for that matter
so it's not always about stress and then
you mentioned the catecholamines which
um are dopamine epinephrine and
norepinephrine so maybe a little bit
later we'll talk about those individual
neurotransmitters but you raise a really
important point which is
something I get asked about a lot for
people that are curious about using
deliberate cold exposure which is how
cold should the water be and I know it's
very hard to give a straight
prescription for that because I think it
boils down to what you just said which
is it's really the difference between
your current temperature and really the
temperature of the surface of your skin
and the temperature of the water so if
you're very warm getting into cold feels
good if you're already cold getting into
more cold feels stressful
um is there any way that we can start to
gauge what is the best way to approach a
deliberate cold exposure protocol I mean
should it feel uncomfortable and that
leads into the question of how do we
balance the discomfort with the amount
of time that we spend in so for instance
if it's just a little bit uncomfortable
we'll spending more time in the cold get
us the same benefit as getting into very
uncomfortably cold water for a very
short period of time yeah it's really
good question and I definitely think
that this could be future studies on
this as well to really unravel uh what
kind of Protocols are the are the best
way or also for which outcomes of course
so if the temperature is very cold and
you feel that you also feel very cold
then you should stay in the water a
little bit longer so I think it's just
you should get uncomfortable cold so as
long as you get uncomfortable cold it's
cold enough and you get this what we
call the code shark so the code stock is
activation of your sympathetic nervous
system and these activation of the the
catecholamines which you just mentioned
before does the shock mean that I'm
having trouble controlling my breathing
is that a good gauge uh yeah you can say
so because that's kind of like how we
Define it so you hyperventilate so you
have a faster
um breathing rate
um so that increases also because you
activate your gasping reflex if you are
new to this
um but if you are adapted it it kind of
subsides with time with the adaptation
so what you can do is that you can train
this cold exposure and you can kind of
like Get adapted to it so you don't have
this hypertension ventilating response
every time you go out in the cold water
so this is like building up your
resilience building building up your
adaptation is gonna make this short like
subside a bit so it's it's always harder
in the beginning but you should do hard
things right it's not something that we
you shouldn't think about cold water and
cold water immersion as something that
is comfortable it should be hard because
that's the point of it right if you
enjoy it then yeah then I'm I'm thinking
something is wrong it's not right you
should not enjoy it well this is an
important point that you're making
because I think that many people shy
away from deliberate cold exposure
because it's uncomfortable
in a way that at least from my
experience is very different than the
discomfort of exercise because with
exercise for instance
um if running hard you know running fast
and breathing hard is uncomfortable you
can slow down or walk if um you know
lifting weights is uncomfortable you can
remove some weight or reduce the number
of repetitions or stop with deliberate
cold exposure I suppose you can be sort
of halfway in halfway out of the water
or partially underneath the cold shower
but it's very hard to titrate and adjust
the level it's kind of all or none and
I've seen um I should just I can tell
this by anecdote I've done some work
with military Special Operations I won't
say which country this was outside the
U.S
um and these are very tough individuals
they're used to going without sleep and
doing hard high consequence higher risk
kind of work
and they were asked to do some cold
water exposure training and I was there
that day and it was remarkable about a
third of them just went straight in and
just kind of grinded through it you know
like they looked stoic anyway to me
um there were a few whimpers no cries
about a third
um
talked a lot and got really you could
tell that they were agitated and anxious
but they made it through and then about
a third of them just simply would not
get in past their knees or thighs we're
just it seemed like they were just
dreading the whole experience someone
actually didn't actually go in
completely
um which was really surprising to me and
that you couldn't tell based on their
physical appearance or anything else
about them they're all high performers
as to who would have this response so it
seems like people vary tremendously in
terms of their ability to embrace the
discomfort of the cold is that from your
studies is that your experience as well
or or are there these weird mutants who
seem to just love going into the cold
for the first time so some people just
feel better in the cold and some people
uh dread the code even more and you can
say the more people are pushing the cold
away they might feel the co-pain even
more so they they they would definitely
people who are maybe the soldiers you
just talked about they some of them
might be already adapted to the gold
cold so if they are not scared of the
cold they go out and they embrace the
COPE in a better way it could also be
that some people have a more sensitive
nervous system and when you are a bit
sensitive to the cold you will of course
try to get away from it right and you
also have the co-pain more um feel the
co-pay more if they're if if you avoid
it so the more you avoid the cold the
the more pain painful it will feel when
you go into it so yeah you mentioned
being outside in a t-shirt versus cold
immersion up to the neck versus shower I
think um this is something a lot of
people wonder about what are the
differences in terms of impact short
term
and perhaps even long term between cold
showers cold plunge to the neck so that
could be in ice water or just very cold
water
immersion with dunking one's head and
then coming up because obviously people
have to come up for air at some point
and then simply being outside on a cold
day in shorts and a t-shirt or something
of that sort so there
it comes because they're they are very
different exposures of the cold to your
co-receptors in your skin so the more
you can say you cover your body in the
cold which you would do in cold water
because there are of course covered
totally and then and the molecules are
closer to your skin you have a more
potent
um activation of all your code receptors
in the skin so that one will definitely
activate your other enormous nervous
system more and Rapid compared to going
out in a t-shirt in the cold wind just
go for a walk
um but that is also something that's
going to activate your sympathetic
nervous system meaning then that you
have an increase in norepinephrine and
you will activate something called the
the brown fat so this is a healthy kind
of fat tissue that we have in our body
and when you activate that that's gonna
increase your metabolism before we talk
about Brown fat and I'm so glad you
brought it up
um because it's so much to talk about
there uh what about cold shower I mean
obviously cold showers somewhere in
between yeah
um being out outside in the Air Cold Air
versus uh being immersed up to the neck
it if we had more studies on on cold
showers we would learn more about how
does that activate our metabolism how
does that increase our neurotransmitters
in the brain which could also have an
impact our on our mental balance so I
think that would be interesting for the
future
um but what we do know is from from from
activating Brown fat and both from
rodent studies but also in humans is
that as soon as we get cold on our skin
we will activate our Brown fat so it is
kind of like our first responder in in
the body to keep our
um temperature up so our muscles is like
the second tissue in our body we have
two tissues which can increase our
thermogenesis so the brown fat which is
like always like temperature regulating
our body and then we have uh the the
muscles which will secondarily start to
shiver and that's going to increase our
um temperature in the body but as soon
as you go into a cold shower you
activate your brown fat also immediately
so it could be good also for increasing
metabolism in theory because we haven't
really any studies showing how much this
actually activate the brown fat so if
someone out there wants to do a study I
think I've thought about why there are
fewer studies of cold showers than cold
immersion and I think the answer to my
mind is that from a methodological
standpoint it's just harder to do
because
if people are getting into cold water up
to the neck they're getting into cold
water up to the neck whereas if people
are getting into a cold shower some
people are larger or smaller some people
are going to stand under the shower with
it hitting their head some people the
back of the neck you could direct people
to do it yeah but it's a little bit um
more difficult also I think uh for you
and I are both research scientists
there's a little bit of a um
methodological challenge that might seem
silly to people but it's a real one
which is if people are in a cold shower
also the water is going to be I'm kind
of pushing their clothing against their
skin there's a certain vulnerability and
for most people coming to a laboratory
in the first place let alone being
observed while they shower whereas when
you get into cold immersion cold
immersion you're getting under the water
and you know some people might roll
their eyes and say okay really is that
the barrier but you know science exists
in these real world contexts and this
will vary by culture and things of that
sort but we run human subjects in my lab
and I'll tell you just um the process of
getting people to the laboratory and
having them Park and find the lab and
you know it's a whole new environment
government with people in lab coats and
people moving around and Where's the
restroom I mean there's there's a
certain amount of stress just associated
with taking part in a study for most
human subjects so
um I uh totally agree however we need
more studies of cold showers it's just a
harder environment to control in my in
my mind so it sounds like any form of
cold to the skin
that people register as what you call
the cold shock or uncomfortable like oh
like this is kind of jarring activates
the brown fat do we know what the
pathway is from cold receptors on the
skin to the brown fat I mean how does
the brown fat know that we're cold yeah
really good question and this seems that
I I think that of course in the future
we will know much more about these
Pathways but what we do know is that the
co-receptors will send a signal to our
temperature regulating Center in in the
brain so hypothalamus
um and that's gonna be
um taking in this message and we have so
many Coke receptors in the skin so it's
going to be very fast as you can say if
you immerse the body into cold water
this is going to be so rapid so it will
have a rapid increase in
neurotransmitters in the brain so no
adrenaline adrenaline and cortisol and
which is not that much but it's but it's
still there so you have this increase in
no adrenaline which will then
immediately activate the the brown fat
because the you can say the activator is
the most potent one cold and no
adrenaline and that's going to activate
the brow fat but there's also a direct
pathway from the cold receptors in the
skin to the to the brown fat which
really shows that if because of these
different Pathways it shows that that it
could be that this tissue to keep us
warm was was
developed in in our evolvement as humans
to keep us warm and to save us whenever
the temperature now on our skin berries
just a little bit to keep us in that
right homeostatic balance so we don't
get hypothermic
um but also so we don't get hyperthermic
but because it seems that the brown fat
is also activated when we get warmer on
our skin so it's also um maybe a
temperature regulator in our in our body
but the pathways is different I think
it's also a third pathway from directly
from the muscles so the brown fat is
also at
um even though the muscles are starting
to shiver so there's an extra pathway
that way to keep our our temperature up
so muscles and brown fat are working
together to to keep us warm so we don't
suffer too much in the in the cold water
it's super interesting and what I here
are you pointing to is the existence of
three parallel Pathways and this notion
of parallel Pathways comes up over and
over again in biology as you and I know
and I mean I think it's important for
people to know about because
um as you uh said so so eloquently the
when something is very important to our
survival or and or evolution
the brain and body uh install multiple
mechanisms for it not just one and um
and so it sounds like it's cold skin
cold on the skin triggers a response in
the hypothalamus which then activates
Brown fat cold receptors in the skin
directly to the brown fat and then
shivering in the muscle to the brown fat
um I want to talk about Brown fat in
depth and learn from you more about
Brown fat
um before that however I want to ask
about shiver
um I've heard that shiver
causes the release of succinate
um which then activates the brown fat is
it known whether or not inducing shiver
is important and when should P people
Shiver I mean I've gotten into cold
plunges and shivered while I was in
there and then I've also had the
experience
of getting into a coal plunger a cold
shower then getting out or even standing
outside on a warm day after swimming in
a pool and then starting to shiver so
the shiver comes later so how important
is shiver and does it matter when shiver
happens
yeah it was shivering is good because
that increases your metabolism and
that's going to burn some calories in
your body you shouldn't be so afraid of
shivering I think because the Shivering
as long as you don't get too hypothermic
so if you don't if you don't sit in the
cold water for too long
um and what you just said by shivering
after you get up that is because of the
after drop something called the after
drop is when your core temperature
decreases even after you get out of the
cold water and it always does that
um your body because it as soon as you
get into the cold water all the your
blood vessels is gonna constrict because
you need to keep your blood in your core
and and keep your vital organ swarm so
as soon as you get up that those blood
vessels will open again and the warm
blood will flow out and get colder and
then flow back again into the core and
that's going to decrease the temperature
in your core of course so that's the
drop so that's the drop yeah I'm so glad
you explained that I've heard years ago
go Wim Hof I heard him talk about the
drop and I've heard colleagues of mine
talk about the drop but that's the first
time I've ever heard it explained
clearly let me make sure I understand
this so um I get into cold water
obviously I'm cold
vessels constrict to keep blood near the
center of my body keep me alive
I get out
the
warming up of my body allows those
vessels and capillaries to dilate again
the blood goes out to the surface but
the surface is still cold and so that
blood is cooled and then my core body
temperature drops and that's what you're
referring to as the drop and that's what
induces shiver exactly right and then am
I right in thinking that then the shiver
activates Brown fat which then warms me
up again yes that's why you should end
on the cold but we can get back to that
yeah let's talk about yes ending on cold
is um you know it's what I refer to as
and what has now become known as the
soberg principle which is um a really
important principle about the importance
of ending on cold
um and not doing what I do which is to
get into a hot shower or back in the
sunroom we'll get back to that in a few
minutes so
um that's wonderful
um that you can explain that so clearly
because I think that shiver is something
that a lot of people do avoid people
think oh I don't want to you know the
chattering of the teeth and um and it
feels like a loss of bodily control
which really it is it's it's an
autonomic response yeah but I don't
think that people should should avoid it
that much it's just like seeing
shivering as a way of your body in in a
like it's training it's training for
your for all yourselves it's training
for your muscles it's training up your
metabolism and that's going to increase
your What's called the insulin
sensitivity so if you can like in your
mind get used to the thought of
shivering is just like when you go
exercising in the training center and
get that feeling of like oh this is
tough now it hurts a little bit yeah
it's gonna hurt because that's what
shivering also does but it's just a
different way of training your cells and
your body it's going to create what is
healthy stress it's called homiesis in
the cells and the more you expose your
your muscle cells or your brown fat
cells to these kind of like healthy
stresses exercise cold and heat exposure
it's gonna make them better at like
activate trading and also um at keeping
you healthy so as long as the cells get
exposed to this it's going to keep them
on its toes you can say because it
becomes more robust and increasing these
heat shock proteins and kosher proteins
in the cells to make you more robust for
the next time and that is also what
happens when you go to the training
center and I keep like drawing that
parallel because people today know more
about we know more about exercise and
what that is is going to do to your
muscle cells and and but the same kind
of like training is also what you do
when you go out and and into the cold
water and submerge into cold water
because that is just your code training
center you can say that and and also
your heat Training Center going into the
sauna because the cells are getting
stronger with hermetic stress so it's
the same process just different
practices
I'm so glad that you brought up the fact
that the discomfort or the embarrassment
or both of shiver is still crucial to uh
actually to reach for and try and
experience the same way that with
exercise
um I think a lot of people don't realize
this but when we did our series with Dr
Andy Galpin
it became clear to me what should have
already been clear to me and I think
that most people don't realize which is
that if we were to measure heart rate
blood pressure stress hormones and
inflammation
in a human being during exercise it
would look as if they were ready to die
blood pressure would be high
inflammation is through the roof but all
of that is setting in motion and
adaptation or set of adaptations that
allow blood pressure to be lower at rest
that allow inflammation markers to be
lower at rest all the things that
everybody is seeking with exercise in
addition to of course the aesthetic
changes that people are seeking with
exercise sounds like the exact same
things are happening with the cold so
the Redundant message here seems to be
that the more discomfort provided it's
done safely just like with exercise the
more shivering
the um the more cold shock provided it's
not to the extreme and stop somebody's
heart right we can talk about thresholds
for that a little bit later
it sounds like all of that is going to
set in motion some long-term changes
that will make people feel better and
will improve health could you just touch
on a few of the longer term changes that
are known to occur
I mean I'm well aware of the study
showing that uh I think it was European
Journal physiology it was uh the
European Journal physiology showing long
lasting increases in catecholamines
dopamine norepinephrine and epinephrine
for many hours after deliberate cold
exposure what are some of the other
things that happen at the level of
metabolism and brown fat in let's say
the hours and day after a deliberate
cold exposure
as soon as you go in of course there's
an activation but it seems like no
you're asking for the the later outcomes
like blood pressure and stuff like that
is that what you mean yeah blood
pressure but also in terms of metabolism
I know that you know in your study you
should and we'll talk about Brown fat in
depth here in a moment but that there
were changes to the brown fat that
equate to changes in for instance
people's ability to be comfortable in
colder environments when they're not
doing deliberate cold exposure or in the
same way that I can um exercise on an
exercise bike or go for a hard run but
then if I go hiking uh with the family
on Sunday and it's a steep climb I could
do that steep climb more easily because
I'm quote unquote fit as a consequence
of the of the exercise what are what are
some of the fitness adaptations of
deliberate cold exposure
yeah so what happens is that you you get
adapted a little bit every time you go
so you will like exercise get a Little
Bit Stronger so every time you go into
the cold water for every time you will
be more exposed to it you will you feel
more comfortable in the code so you're
gonna you're gonna build your adaptation
which happens on a metabolic level which
is going to be the brown fat so you'll
have more activation of your brown fat
the mitochondria in the the brown fat
cells are going to be
um you have more of those and they will
be more efficient at heating you up
because it expects the body expects you
to to do this again so you are prepared
in a way the capillaries in your skin is
also it will also become better at like
constricting so you will have a better
Shield of your body to prepare you for
the next time so you will be become
better at going into the cold water in
that way so the body makes this
mechanism and changes your body in a way
so you can expose yourself to the next
time right and and also you will have um
also um your um stress response will
also be subside a bit so you have a less
increase of your catecholamines
um with time
with time also you have because of this
activation of your brown fat or your
muscles you have an increase in them in
in your metabolism which will then make
your insulin sensitivity better and this
is shown in in studies for example um
there's this interesting study I found
just before I I started my PhD which was
from um keeper stoma
um at L from 2016 where they measured um
metabolism
and not in not on Brown fat but they
measured insulin sensitivity in
middle-aged men and women during one
winter swimming season so they were not
very young like they were in my study
but they were they were middle aged and
I think this is very interesting so they
during these four or five months they
were winter swimming they saw that they
had a lower blood pressure after the
season and they had a lower heart rate
and they also so that they have a better
insulin sensitivity and I think that is
very interesting because if you can have
a better insulin sensitivity you can
prevent lifestyle diseases so and with
lower blood pressure which is a very
strong outcome also for selling how much
inflammation you have in the body and
because it didn't measure Brown fat I
figured that it could be that was the
missing link that was the one of the
explanations to why we see this um less
inflammation in the body
so um the longer outcomes the long-term
outcomes could be that you lower your
blood pressure and have a lower heart
rate and you also
um have a better insulin sensitivity and
better glucose balance but that was
shown it that is shown in my study I'd
like to take a quick break and
acknowledge one of our sponsors athletic
greens athletic greens now called ag-1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that covers all of your foundational
nutritional needs I've been taking
athletic greens since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health and those
probiotics and athletic greens are
optimal and vital for microbiotic health
in addition athletic greens contains a
number of adaptogens vitamins and
minerals that make sure that all of my
foundational nutritional needs are met
and it tastes great if you'd like to try
athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 and
we'll get back to the insulin
sensitivity and glucose balance that's a
in an impressive list of benefits
um you know blood pressure of course
most people are aware of blood pressure
and what it is it's what they measure
when we go to the doctor and it's not
very sexy nowadays you know blood
pressure people oh you know blood
pressure it's not you know people want
to hear about the inflammatorium and the
microbiome and all of that stuff is
really interesting but
um I think that blood pressure doesn't
get enough
attention
and we have spoken to on this podcast to
Dr Peter attia who um is an expert in
longevity and health span and things of
that sort and and I was surprised to
learn again I shouldn't have been
surprised that the number one reason
people die worldwide is cerebral
vascular disease and cardiovascular
disease and there are basically three
things on the list of things to address
one is not smoking or vaping by the way
uh not to get there are a few other
things related to blood markers apob and
things of that sort but then the big one
is blood pressure and so it's it's
interesting because we don't think about
blood pressure that much anymore
um as a as the kind of people interested
in health optimization and health but
blood pressure is so vital to control so
it's wonderful to hear that deliberate
cold exposure is one way to control
blood pressure I'm guessing in concert
with other forms of exercise yeah um
let's talk about Brown fat and um if you
if you're willing I'd love to drill into
Brown fat at a deep level
um again my understanding of this is is
far more Elementary than yours
obviously you're the expert my
understanding about Brown fat
is that it's located in specific areas
of our body
uh maybe more widespread than when I
learned in school I thought it was I was
taught it was just at the clavicles in
the back of the neck and upper back but
who knows I learned that there's more of
it when we're children
maybe more distributed throughout our
body
and that it's rich in mitochondria but
what is so special about the brown fat
like if we could just go into the
biology of brown fat a little bit what
does it look like you've measured it in
human subjects where is it distributed
really can it expand its distribution
can we activate and expand the amount of
brown fat as adults and um for those of
you that are cringing already thinking
we're talking about getting fatter it's
quite the opposite we're talking about
not subcutaneous fat but fat located
around the the organs but please educate
me um tell me where I'm wrong and expand
my knowledge on Brown fat
okay yeah you're not wrong but um it's
definitely it's true that there are more
locations of the brown fat than we
previously thought
um there's this very nice study from
2017 by Leitner L where they had made
these opacities uh overlays of um their
subjects but you can see where in the
body do we have brown fat and where can
we grow more Brown fat
um so to say um so the brown fat is is
very plastic so it means that it can it
can grow and they can decrease and this
is proven in in studies where we have
seen um
um people with a fair cryocytoma it's
like a very specific cancer type where
people where from the 70s where we can
see that if they have this specific kind
of a cancer type
um they have a they have this tumor on
the adrenal gland so they have like a
huge increase in NOAA adrenaline and
because of that you don't have this
continuous activation of the brown fat
and they have grown a lot of brown fat
in the whole body or abdominal where
it's located in these six different
places but it is just like very much
compared to like normal people
um and what they then see what we
learned from this study is that brown
fat can apparently grow if you have an
increase in no adrenaline in the body
it's not like you want that because when
that happens you have a high blood
pressure you don't want it chronically
right you just want it on like a short
amount of time and then it can grow for
a bit but you don't want it chronically
of course not but because it it
activates also your sympathetic nervous
system so they have also showed they
have high blood pressure they had
they lost a lot of weight of course
because this is activating your
metabolism so they they found luckily
that when they removed this benign a
tumor uh that uh the brown fat
um decreases again to normal size and
they gain weight again and they had
normal blood pressure so the story ends
well but it's kind of like proof of
concept of the brown fat can actually
grow so it's plastic in its in its way
of like it can grow and it can decrease
again so that's very good good studies
to to see what what the body is capable
of but we don't of course want all that
brown fat we just want it to be um we
just want to keep it actually and keep
it activated because what we see in
studies is also that after the age of 40
and people
um Studies have shown that there is an
association with having less brown fat
but increased obesity so of course we we
don't know yet whether a brown fat
decreases with A's and therefore before
we get obese or we get obese and
therefore we have less brown fat but as
brown fat is an insulin sensitive organ
in our body and we get obese just like
the muscles get less sensitive insulin
sensitive the brown fat does as well and
therefore it maybe decreases it could be
a theory that I think could be one of
the reasons why we don't see that much
Brown fat in in elderly people some have
a lot especially people working outside
there are studies showing this who
people who work outside do physical work
outside farmers and
um yeah interesting yeah yeah thanks
post themselves to it so they'll just
keep it in that way it's
um and I suppose we should um clarify
for people in case they don't know that
insulin sensitivity is a very good thing
you want that you want your cells to be
sensitive to insulin insulin
insensitivity is type 2 diabetes and is
associated with obesity
um so just a point of clarification
there
uh yeah it's interesting to me I I I
usually work out at home but I go to a
gym once or twice a week if I can
because it's good if I see uh the
outside world
um and there are a few individuals at
the the gym who are they're not
particularly large or muscular
um but they are incredibly
um lean and their posture is great
presumably from the musculoskeletal work
um and they they're in their 70s and 80s
I mean it's remarkable right and um and
I know all the telltale signs of hormone
augmentation I'm very good at spotting
that there are a few telltale signs I've
talked about this on other podcasts and
they're not that's not why they're
they're they're they're
um they're fit they're they're clearly
of that look and you see this written
outside the gym too of course for people
that look like they've done a lot of
physical labor their whole life yeah
they're just moving a lot they have
strong hands and features and they're
um and they're not necessarily except
aggressively lean but you can tell that
they've been using their musculoskeletal
system and I like to talk to these
people and ask them like not what are
you doing now for your workout but what
what did you grow up doing you know and
I would say and obviously I haven't run
statistics on this but
more than 75 percent of them respond
that they grew up on a farm
or that they did some sort of
manual labor or were a postman or a
postwoman or doing something where they
moved a lot for their early years and
throughout middle age and most of them
are now in retirement but some of them
are still working and they all still
moving a lot so
the relationship between shiver and
brown fat makes sense to me but is it
the case that as we're just moving
around I've heard of neat non-exercise
induced thermogenesis so if we're just
moving around that we are activating
Brown fat or does there need to be this
stressor does there need to be shiver
and a cold stimulus or a heat stimulus
to activate the brown fat in other words
is just staying active enough or do we
need to do some sort of temperature uh
shock type thing like deliberate cold
exposure yeah I think that is a really
good question because how how also why
do we have this tissue then if it's if
it has to be extreme then you can
question what what do we need this
tissue for but it seems that you can
activate the brown fat with just a
little bit of exposure to to cold so
cold is the most potent stress or
activator of our Brown fat because it's
our temperature regulating organ in our
body so first responder to that so the
muscles will be a little bit too late
and therefore we have maybe these two
kind of tissues so actually just
exposing yourself or a hand actually
just to cold water so Studies have shown
um that if you just put your hand in
cold water not that you're going to
going to do that all day or or every day
or anything it's not it's it's not
something you have to do but it just
shows that you can activate your brown
fat just by getting a temperature change
on your skin so you can go outside and
t-shirts that's why also we were just
talking about well people who works
outside or move a lot or get out in and
out of it like changing the temperature
of the body all the time they will have
more Brown fat and activating that is
going to keep your metabolism higher and
your insulin sensitivity is that it has
also shown this so the brown fat can be
activated as soon as you just change
your temperature in the skin so going
outside in a t-shirt wearing cooling
vests also Studies have shown this for
10 days it's gonna also grow your your
brown fat so you can get more Brown fat
if you expose yourself to the cold you
don't have to start in a cold shower you
don't have to start in a cold plunge if
you're not really ready for that yet but
just exposing yourself to a wind has
also shown to activate your brown fat or
if you don't want to be like in this
awake state then you can also just sleep
in the cold and you won't notice it that
much maybe but Studies have shown that
if you sleep in 19 degrees Celsius and
then you will activate your brown fat
and you will grow your ground fat so you
have more of it so this is in very nice
studies
um
from Hansen Adele from 2017 showed that
a group of subjects who slept in a room
at 24 degrees and then they made this
Pet City scannings to see how much Brown
fat do they have from the beginning so
what we call Baseline then they measured
again after a month of sleeping in 19
degrees and they saw I think it's
remarkable just one month at 19 degrees
sleeping there they had a duet on and
they were still had clothes on when they
were sleeping so they're under a
covered yeah yeah the subjects were
sleeping
one month had increased is insulin
sensitivity the next month they stepped
at 24 degrees they measured this again
and then they had decreased actually a
little bit and then they slept at 27
degrees so quite warm room actually for
for the fourth month um and they saw a
even less activation of the brown fat
and also insulin sensitivity so it seems
that you can expose yourself and pretty
rapidly the brown fat will respond to
this because it's so sensitive to no
adrenaline right so if you keep exposing
yourself to a little bit of coal you
also get a little bit adapted to it but
that's because the brown fat
um has grown these more mitochondria in
the cells so these small energy Fabrics
that's going to activate the cells and
that's going to take up glucose and fat
from the fatty acids from the
bloodstream to keep the thermogenesis up
and that's going to clear up some sugar
and it's going to click so in the in the
bloodstream and some some fat as well so
the brown fat can in that way decrease
our unhealthy fat which is the white fat
and the white fat is what we don't want
too much of but we still need some of
course
and it's our energy storage so it's very
important that it's there we just don't
need a lot of it so on our thighs and
also around our inner organs that's
where it's it's located so if we can
have activation of the brown fat just by
going out in the cold and just by
sleeping in a cold room or if you are
have courage for it you can go out and
expose yourself in a coat plunge
um cold showers is also going to do the
trick so you can do different variations
of this just exposing yourself to
various temperatures it's going to
activate the brown fat because it was
involved to keep us in a perfect
homeostatic balance regarding
temperature so to Keep Us Alive
incredible uh I want to just get a
clarification around this 19 degrees
Celsius room that they're sleeping in so
they're under a comforter a duvet and um
and you mentioned they had clothes on
the room is 19 degrees Celsius but the
temperature underneath their blanket
might not be 19 degrees Celsius so
presumably it's the cold on their face
that's activating uh the the increase in
brown fat that was observed is that is
that a reasonable expectation I I think
so yeah because it's you have so many
co-receptors in your face so it's
actually it's enough and I think it
corresponds very well with the studies
showing that you can activate the brown
fat just by putting a hand into a bucket
of cold water and I did this experiment
myself in in my studies just to see how
well did they respond to cold water so
it was a four degrees Celsius cold water
for four minutes and then I just met
your blood pressure on heart rate to see
do they have like an activation of this
I actually also measured the brown fat
during this cold exposure for four
minutes with an infrared thermography
camera to see can I see that the brown
fat is activated and just just to go
back to the location of the brown fat so
usually you cannot really see activation
of your brown fat because it's located
centrally in your around your central
nervous system
um and and the biggest Depot as you
mentioned before is up here under the
clavicular bones so
um and very close to the skin surface
and because it's so close to the skin
surface I could measure it with this
very expensive camera here and it's not
very feasible for people to go home and
do this don't because it takes a lot of
practice I can tell
um but we measured the brown fat with
this um and and I could see that after a
few minutes that the activation was
there an increase in temperature arose
from that activation just four minutes
so it's very rapid and I'm also measured
in my study how deep was the brown fat
under your skin so it's very close to
the surface which also shows that it it
needs to be there to heat you up and
heat your inner organs well I'm
delighted to hear all of this and I'll
tell you why one is by way of anecdote I
mentioned a little bit earlier that as
an undergraduate I worked in a lab that
studied thermogenesis and we were doing
that in animals but we had this room
that was very cold the whole room was
called the guy who I worked for at the
time and I'm Harry Carlyle is a very
accomplished physiologist he came from
this lineage I don't know if this
literature is still um discussed much
but it's a beautiful literature
um from Rothwell and stock they were the
ones who discovered um non-exercise
induced thermogenesis the fact that
people bounce who bounce their legs a
lot and move around a lot and have a lot
of kind of um stochastic movement
um burn up to 18
00 calories more per day than people who
sit more still fascinating incredible
and just incredible
um I don't think that work does gets as
much attention as it deserves publishing
journals like nature so very uh fine
journals but in any event
uh one of the things that I noticed when
I started working in that laboratory was
that I was cold because the room was
cold and um Dr Carlisle Harry
um said well the key is to wear a
t-shirt in here for about two or three
days and then you will cold adapt I
thought well wouldn't I want to put on a
hoodie and get warm in there so I was
comfortable and he said no actually what
you want to do is get yourself
uncomfortably cold activate your brown
fat and indeed when I did that I think
it was just two days of being in that
cold environment then I could come back
on the third day and be perfectly
comfortable yeah because the brown fat
had expanded
um or or added mitochondria or both and
I was perfectly comfortable in that
environment I also got very very lean in
those um in those days and weeks now
I've never been somebody who's very lean
nor am I somebody who carries a lot of
excess adipose tissue I'm kind of
somewhere in the middle I'm sure I could
adjust that with feeding if I want to
but it was it was striking uh what a
powerful effect it had on my entire
system of thermal regulation and one of
the things that I uh also delighted in
when cell reports
um medicine published your study is they
had in an accompanying um press release
that went out to to those of us that
received press releases and it described
a um a saying in Scandinavia which is um
essentially I'm not going to attempt to
uh speak uh Danish even though I have
much of my family is in Denmark I
believe or not from Denmark
um we have a lot of Danes in my family
um I won't embarrass myself by trying to
speak Danish as I did before the the
microphones were rolling but
um that there's a saying that I think
essentially translates to in the fall
when when you're approaching winter you
want to actually wear fewer layers not
bundle up when you go outside so that
you can prepare yourself for the cold of
winter and be able to heat yourself up
using your brown fat and that in the
spring as the temperatures are warming
rather than removing layers you want to
wear more layers in order to be a little
bit uncomfortably warm so that In the
Heat of the summer you're better at
cooling your body do I have that right
and maybe do you know the saying and
would you be willing to share it only
the swedes and um uh and Danes will be
able to understand
um maybe the Norwegians too if you don't
know it that's okay yeah so I know that
I know the the concept of it because we
say it you should you should wear a less
before winter and and more before summer
so there it is in English so it doesn't
have to be esoteric but okay yeah and
and you're completely right and I think
this is the this is just something that
we know in the Scandinavian countries I
think that we we
intuitively know this but if we just go
back a little bit in history I think
that um around the 1950s the the Russian
government went out and said well we
should do something about the
tuberculosis pandemic or epidemic make
the worse at the this time so that they
wanted to have the the people
um
be more resilient to the cold and also
increase our immune system so in
Scandinavia and actually also in Russia
we put our babies outside to sleep in
the prom and that is like to uh also to
to get more resistance to the coal but
also to increase our immune system and
we still do that in Denmark so we we
really yeah we do babies are taken out
in the cold in the snow in Frosty rain
everything my two boys have been
sleeping out in winter or at least the
their first many three four five years
because it's like very good for them and
they get a better immune system and get
resilient to the cold so they will have
less colds and also they run around in a
t-shirt when it's super cool because
they have activated all the brown fat I
didn't understand at that time I must I
must say but I kind of like intuitively
also knew because we have inherited this
way of doing things with our culture so
and I have heard people coming from the
U.S saying things are crazy they put the
babies outside and problems and leave
them there and then they go inside and
drink coffee on the cafe
well I don't think Danes are crazy I I I
I Adore the date they're amazing uh
culture and people I'm so fortunate to
have family members uh from Denmark but
I did notice so when when we were in
Copenhagen and I know um we we saw you
there uh not long ago that was June
um the water in the harbor was was cold
for even though the Pacific is close to
here which is very cold I was felt
pretty cold but I it was summertime ish
um so people were in summertime mode
right t-shirts and shorts and things
that that sort but it did strike me that
people in Copenhagen are
dramatically fitter than they are in the
United States I mean first of all
everyone's bicycling everywhere yeah
um not many people wearing sunglasses so
trying to extract as much Photon energy
from the Sun as possible which I support
uh as everyone knows that's I'm a big
fan of getting Sun but also
um when we did see swimmers
um they were swimming in this cold water
and like it was nothing and their the
range in age of the swimmers was what
was remarkable you saw the kind of fit
triathlete looking types but also young
kids like really young kids and then
people probably in there again they're
they're 70s 80s maybe even 90s really uh
remarkable uh vastly different than what
you see if you go to the ocean here in
Los Angeles or or elsewhere so
um yeah you Scandinavians are on to
something with this I'd like to take a
quick break and thank our sponsor inside
tracker inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done the simple reason that many of the
factors that impact your immediate and
long-term Health can only be assessed
with a quality blood test the problem
with a lot of blood and DNA tests out
there however is that they'll give you
information about certain lipid markers
or hormone markers but no information
about what to do with all of that data
inside tracker makes it very easy to
look at your levels of hormones
metabolic factors lipids Etc and then to
assess what sorts of Behavioral
nutritional supplementation or perhaps
other interventions you might want to
use in order to bring those numbers into
the ranges that are optimal for your
health inside tracker's ultimate plan
now includes three new hormone markers
that are critical to measure during a
woman's reproductive and menopausal
years these are estradiol progesterone
and thyroid stimulating hormone if you'd
like to try inside tracker you can go to
insidetracker.com huberman to get 20 off
any of inside trackers plans again
that's inside tracker.com huberman to
get 20 off
I'd like to talk about your study
if you could give us a little bit of the
backdrop about what motivated that study
and then um and then walk us through
what you did you know who the subjects
were
um what you had them do what you
measured
um in as much detail as you would like
to share because I think it's such an
important you know even fair to say
landmark study because it also explored
not just cold but sauna and the the
co-use of cold and sauna as a way to
probe metabolism and brown fat and other
markers as well and as you do this uh
I'm hoping at some point that you might
tell us some of the observations that
you might have made that interested you
that perhaps were not in the paper
because that's one of the great benefits
of sitting across from somebody who who
did the work in detail so um yeah if you
could tell us about your study um and uh
what you did and what you discovered
thank you for the question Andrew I I'd
love to like also explain a little bit
what did we do because when people read
this kind of paper they just see the
numbers they don't see what what
happened before that and human studies
are very different from from my study my
studies you can do a knockout of
something and then everything is like
perfectly matched and controlled doing
humans studies is very far different
from that because people are different
even in the groups so yeah but what we
um
when I started this research in 2016 I
did not really know what the brown fat
was so I started reading up on all this
and I was very interested in preventive
medicine and also the studies that I did
before Brown fat was also like very much
in the preventive side like how can we
that was about something else but the
Sweet Tooth and how can we lower our
sweet tooth and stuff like that so but
after that I wanted to to do something
new so I looked into the brown fat got
hired in this fantastic research group
where they it's a cell group so they
mostly did cell studies and they didn't
have anyone to do a human study yet
um and um but they really wanted me to
to do that so I read upon a lot of
research about how does the brown fat
get activated what have been done
already and I mentioned the paper before
with sleeping in the cold I found that
particular paper very fascinating and
that was also where
um at that time I was like okay so cold
exposure sure as an intervention of
sleeping in the cold could be a good
thing to go out and say well people do
this but on the other hand is first of
all it was already done that was one
thing but the other thing was like well
I wanted to to see if we can do it like
some kind of activity so we can have
people move also go and do something do
something together or whatever and and
the code made us think about well what
about winter swimming and it was kind of
like a bit of a joke in the beginning
it's like winter swimming yeah it's
going to activate the brown fat right
but but when we read the literature we
couldn't really find anything about
activation of the brown fat with cold
water besides hand in a bucket of cold
water that really that was already there
so we were just thinking okay so it
should be very potent
um activation of the brown fat if it's
cold water but very different from cold
air so it was kind of also a new thing
we were going into and we knew that we
were going to do like a more of a proof
of concept study at the beginning of it
because it was like winter swimmers
um most in theory activate the brown fat
right but we kind of didn't really know
with was this kind of stressor too much
too little or what will happen actually
but we had this idea about well we
always say that cold water and winter
swimming will activate your metabolism
but do but do we know if it does that no
we don't so
um and while this idea was a little bit
fun fun at the beginning and we kind of
accepted it it was like okay let's just
try this out but because we didn't have
the funding for it we was like okay
let's do a proof of concept study
um let's go with a small number but
enough to see um a difference between
the groups so the power calculation of
that study is done on what we know from
Pet City scannings of the brown fat so
that's the main outcome of that of
course so
um and we wanted to go a little bit
smaller on the numbers of participants
because we wanted to dig a little bit
deeper into the different mechanisms and
also redo some of the the days so I
really wanted to do that to see if I can
replicate also the findings and that's
going to take a lot of a lot of funding
but it's also going to take a lot of
time to do it
um so the proof of concept was just
going small but looking at different
mechanisms we also took
um fat biopsies for example and looked
at the white fat to see if there was any
differences between the groups before
and after and stuff like that so that's
kind of like how it started and and the
first year was like a field study for me
so I was not a winter swimmer when I
started this it was just oh really no I
wasn't
um at all and I would say I was a bit
afraid of the cold myself a bit of a
cold uh always cold having big
socks on and sweaters and stuff like
that so I was like I am so comfortable
I'm just like everybody else very
comfortable I like being income
completely temperature neutral and but I
started like playing with this thought
like well if this is so healthy in
theory I should not pack myself up I
should start not doing that
yeah but the first year observation of
winter swimmers under Jetty they kind of
joked about is they come on you need to
try this you cannot study this um unless
you have tried it
and I was like haha very funny of course
I can do that
but I couldn't I I read the literature I
understood in theory what happens when
you go into cold water but I completely
understood it when I first tried it the
first few times not so funny it felt
painful it was just like running too
long after a long break and you and your
muscles hurt the day after right you you
completely regret that you took that
extra mile what about when you say
uncomfortable you mean uncomfortable
when you got in and when you were in or
uncomfortable afterwards because I find
that um on rare occasions well I should
just a full disclosure I I do deliberate
cold exposure every morning for about a
minute to two minutes in a cold plunge
there are days that I miss but when I'm
at home I do that and when I travel I do
a cold shower I do finish with a warm
shower so um and we'll talk about why
that's probably not the best idea but um
and I've been doing it for some years
now
um on and off uh but so just full
disclosure I'm a devotee
um and I have family members that uh
hate the the cold but have gotten into
it and and are starting to like it but
they don't and I don't necessarily like
the experience in the cold water but I
love the way I feel when I get out and I
have I'm a hundred percent on that
statement about loving it when I get out
occasionally it feels good to be in
there it feels invigorating and I think
I've learned to control the gasp reflex
and the hyperventilation and I just have
told myself what we know which is that
the forebrain struggles to engage for
the first 20 or 30 seconds but if you
can get past that wall it's it's far
easier to to push through
um but when you say that it was really
uncomfortable do you mean the experience
of getting in or you also felt lousy
afterward yeah it's and very important
to clear that out I only felt very
uncomfortable doing it at the moment but
afterwards the first time I went with
with the group and actually my husband
was there as well because I I really
wanted someone I knew
um coming along because it's very normal
if you haven't done this before you feel
a little bit anxious about it and this
is jonon studies as well because blood
pressure and heart rate goes up in in
those who are new to this kind of
activity so um I was a little bit
anxious about it so it was really
uncomfortable just doing it but
afterwards as soon as I got up I felt
fantastic and we went into the sauna and
I did three rounds because I just loved
it I loved the feeling afterwards
because you have all these nutrients
minutes going in your brain and you feel
more positive you feel I feel invigorate
I had so much energy and that like I I
could totally see why people would do
this to get energy throughout the day
because I definitely had that I didn't
have to do 3 three dips to to get that I
think one would be enough and I often do
that also now today I do one dip
sometimes I do two or three dips in in
one round you can say in one day but
often it's like just one or two times a
week for me that is enough to to get
that energy and to get that positive
feeling and and I think that that is
also why I I put up my study in that way
I wanted to study the lowest dose you
can say the lowest amount that we can
get away with but still see
um health benefits so what I observed
there on the jetty was that some did it
a long time they were in the water for a
very long time and to me it seemed maybe
a little bit extreme could you give me
an example of long time well so maybe
they were like really swimming and they
could be 20 minutes or half an hour
that's a long time that's a long time
and there was like ice and people who
came up I mean
I just didn't really feel that this is
something that I wanted to go out and
recommend to people after my community
research subjects dying either because
if you're not adapted I mean the people
you know people can do that also a 20
minute cold shower or 20 minute cold
plunge I know people do it but it's
probably not a good idea no probably not
it's gonna exhaust yourselves and make
them age too fast fast so exactly that's
when you pass that hermetic stress the
healthy stress level that's what is
happening the quite opposite is almost
chronic stress actually in the cells
well what happened then was that um I
found out if if I want to have this
protocol get through ethical committee I
I really needed to go like very like
Sleek with the not too long and and make
sure that they were also very healthy
and and to get approval of course of
this study
um but what I did was to to recruit
winter swimmers who already have been
swimming for two or three seasons and I
just observed them I said I'm not gonna
do an intervention study yet I did that
after but I I wanted to do like a proof
of concept where they were already
adapted to the cold and then compare
them to a match control group who were
matched on
um on you could say diet so whether they
vegetarian or not
um and one of them worse in each group
uh also they weren't all vegetarians no
no no just one in each group yeah it's
gonna say with all the amazing fish and
meat in uh in Denmark I'd have a hard
time being a vegetarian no the breads
are amazing the fruits and vegetables
too but okay so there were a couple
vegetarians in each group yeah one one
in each yeah okay and then I'm
vegetarian I have family members of
vegetarians so I've just poking fun yeah
yeah but they were they were matched on
different things so what we usually
match the mono is also BMI
um which shows one gender in this study
and we would always choose both men and
women normally but we do see that there
are different Brown fat levels depending
on gender so women have more Brown fat
than men really yeah interesting yeah I
think it's interesting uh a deserved
study yeah yeah why actually I think
it's interesting because women are also
smaller so in size and mass right but
they also have
um a lower peripheral temperature
especially on hands and ears and is that
right that's that's documented that what
women do run colder than men yeah and
physiologically I didn't say
psychologically no no no we won't we
won't go to the psychological
yeah something else that's a different
podcast yeah
so women are just colder physically
so on hands and ears it's measured on
that
um and and and feet as well so compared
to men and men have bigger Hearts than
women and they can pump out more blood
peripheral than in a woman's body so
they that could be an explanation for
the colder hands for example
some comfortable state is also different
between genders so men are more
comfortable at 22 degrees Celsius and
women are thermal comfortable at 24
degrees Celsius and this is the
thermostat Wars of home have been now
validated
two degrees Celsius by the way prior to
um starting recording uh I made the
executive decision that we were going to
go with Celsius throughout the podcast
um because the majority of the world
uses Celsius so for those of you that
think in Fahrenheit
um the internet is your friend in making
those conversions so we're sticking with
Celsius so men tend to be Thermo
comfortable at 22 degrees Celsius women
at 24. okay interesting explains a lot
about like also some arguments in the
homes where men are turning down the
heater and women are turning up the
heater and they cannot really so it's
it's really it's I'm on both sides here
I understand the men we understand the
women but it's there is a difference
there which was also one of the reasons
why we had we in this proof of concept
study chose one gender so it is not like
only because we wanted to study man it
was just to see to eliminate uh all the
confounding factors which could have an
impact on on our results so
um that was one of the reasons
um but also because we yeah so women
have have more Brown fat than men and
otherwise we would have to like do four
groups or something like that and not
having funding yet we were like okay we
need to do like just one a group just a
control group and then and a group who
will always winter swimmers so I
recruited winter swimmers who have been
swimming for two to three seasons
um because I wanted them to be already
adapted but not going too long in the
water so they told me I did a lot of
screening here of course beforehand and
interviews to see to ask them how much
do you do and
um how much do you how long do you stay
in the water and I monitored how long
did they didn't stay in the water and
recruited based on
um that they only did like two to three
times per week it seems reasonable for
for Denmark at least to do that and they
stayed only in the water for one to two
minutes so the coastal subsides very
quickly and you will get this activation
of your rest and digest system which is
your parasympathetic nervous system so
the the other branch of your other
enormous nervous system and you get that
activation because you submerged into
cold water and when you do that you have
an activation of your diving response
and that's gonna slow down the you can
say the the cons Assumption of oxygen
also in your body and that's going to
slow down your heart rate could I pause
you on this because I've heard this
before that when we get into cold water
shower or immersion we get this
sympathetic autonomic response so
increased blood pressure increased heart
rate release of norepinephrine from the
locus ceruleus in the brain release of
um adrenaline dopamine adrenaline from
the from the adrenals
dopamine presumably within the brain
but that the parasympathetic response is
activated when we put our face into cold
water or go underwater and that's a
calming relaxation response
so this brings us back to I don't want
to take us off track from you describing
the study but this brings us back to the
first question which is if I go
completely underwater for a moment when
I start my cold plunge does that change
the physiological outcome as compared to
if I just submerge myself up to the neck
and that and actually nowadays there's
it seems to be a little bit of a
movement online of people putting a bowl
of ice water on their countertop and
submerging their face into it did you
see this this is a start obviously more
and more posts about this so um could
you just touch on the what the dive
reflex is and why it act perhaps
activates the parasympathetic response
this calming response
but also the diving reflex is activated
when you submerge into cool water
um even just to the neck yeah or I
thought you had to get your face under
I'm not I'm not arguing different you're
the expert I just wanna yeah I haven't
really I haven't read that I've just
seen that you can activate your uh that
diving response as soon as you go
underwater with your body
um so you don't have to do it with your
face as far as I understand I could I
could be wrong though
um yeah so when when you activate your
diving response you will slow down your
um your oxygen consumption in your body
and that is because the body tries to
preserve
um oxygen so you will not get
hypothermic too fast so it's kind of
like a survival system in your body
um so this survival system is very
um important for us of course so that
would be activated and because of that
you will have to maybe one minute or so
I'm that can be precise on that because
I maybe it also varies a bit in humans
so one to two minutes you will have full
activation of the sympathetic nervous
system but also the parasympathetic
nervous system
um and that's going to activate for
example something like serotonin in your
brain which is like also good for mental
balance and people feeling in mental
balance afterwards they after they go up
you know so that is like measured on a
questionnaires and also measure like on
anecdotes of course people tell all the
time that they feel good afterwards we
need studies on this so if anyone's
sitting out there thinking that's
interesting then please do some studies
on that to get more out of that yeah
so you had so you observed these winter
swimmers who are done this for a few
seasons yeah they're coming around for a
new season of winter swimming and you've
decided to recruit them as subjects
they are getting into cold water
um climbing down a ladder or jumping
into the water up to their neck yeah
climbing yeah okay climbing down a
ladder into it because it's done
Outdoors what a fun study to do my
graduate thesis was done under
fluorescent lights with no windows in a
in a building that uh I mean I had a ton
of fun as a PhD student I actually lived
in the laboratory as a PhD student I
loved it so much but um not something
required to do a PhD by the way but um
they're climbing down the ladder yeah
getting it up to their neck staying in
for one to two minutes
and then getting out and how many times
a week are they doing this so to do this
two to three times per week and for each
time they go each day they go they take
three rounds off so three dips and two
sauna sessions so they start in the cold
and they end in the cold water okay so
it's get in for one to two minutes then
get out and get into the sauna yeah
um what is the temperature of the sauna
about 80 degrees Celsius okay then how
long are they in the sauna so they
stayed there for 10 to 15 minutes so
depending on if they went two times per
week or three times per week okay and
then they get back into the cold for a
few minutes two minutes up to two
minutes yeah okay then back into the
sauna 15 minutes or so yeah then back
into the cold for a third round yeah
back into the sauna
and then then they're ending and then
back into the cold again and then ending
on cold yeah and uh and we'll talk about
why it's important to end on cold the
so-called sober principle
um how cold was the water in this
particular given average because I
realized it's outdoor winter swimming so
it's going to vary depending on wind
chill and things as well of course so
it's a very uncontrolled environment to
do this kind of study then but I wanted
to do something that was also very close
to something people could do for free
going out in nature and use that and
also have the nature like it's very
healthy impact on us it lowers our
stress stress level as well so
by doing so I also measured the
temperature every time they went so I
have this graph and it's actually in the
winter swimming book it shows the
temperature in Denmark going like from
October to April and it's like it starts
at 12 degrees I think it's around 12 to
12 degrees Celsius and the water and
then it goes down to two degrees in on
average in January and then up again
um so it's within the spectrum of very
cold water I would say from around 15 15
degrees Celsius and down but it was
actually not colder than like two to
four degrees in in on average when it
was the coldest so it doesn't have to be
that cold to be good enough and and
enough to activate our metabolism
um and what time of day are
um the participants doing this cold
sauna alternation so I think they did
this uh throughout the day so I didn't
control whether they wanted to go in the
morning in the afternoon or in the
evening at that time where I set up this
study I would I was not controlling it
in that way I wanted them to go whenever
they had time and I also think that is
the most important message to give to
give to people is to do it when you have
time it's not if if doing it when you
get home from work and it's six o'clock
in the evening and this is the time
where you are where you can do it and
then then try out if it's going to
impact your sleep or not if it doesn't
impact your sleep then fine but you have
to try for yourself and find out what
works for you it's the same for coffee
for example right some people can drink
coffee in the evening and go to bed and
they can sleep I can't or exercise or
exercise exactly so I can't I can't do
that and that's because the coffee
exercise cold water and immersion is
going to activate your sympathetic
nervous system you haven't increase in
stress response in your body and and
that's going to make it really hard to
fall asleep for some people at least
maybe you are super exhausted anyways
and then you will just crash anyways but
yeah but um that's that's the only thing
so I just told them to do this if they
can during the daytime
um and that's primarily what they also
did and then uh all along you're
measuring Brown fat by way of this
infrared uh camera right
um so what did you observe in terms of
changes in brown how quickly did that
occur and um and then I'd like to ask
also about sauna a bit more because
earlier you mentioned that you can
activate round fat with sauna as well
with heat surface of the skin
um
how long did it take before you observed
significant increases in brown fat and
was it increased density of my brown fat
or distribution was it you know showing
expansion to different regions
throughout the body and maybe you could
also touch on some of the changes in
insulin sensitivity and Metabolism yeah
a very good question and and I didn't
mention this before but besides
measuring
um temperature as an outcome for brown
fat activity we also did pet MRI
scanning of the brown fat so this is
like the the golden standard for
measuring Brown fat and it's not very
feasible for normal people to get an and
a pet a CT or pet MRI a scanning of the
brown fat is super expensive
um so we had both uh to see if we could
have like a continuous measure of brown
fat in humans because that was already
not not out there so I wanted to see
during both the experience governmental
days but also during day and night what
kind of like circadian rhythm do we have
in our Brown fat activity so that's why
I wanted to have that as well so the Pet
City scanning or the pit MRI scanning
was to see upon code activation
um stimulation for some hours do we have
activation can we see the brown fat in
this subject and also during Thermo
neutrality or thermal comfortable State
how is that activated in each of the
group of course ah so you want to see
how comfortable people were away from
the cold water and sauna just had
different temperature environments is
that right yeah so I also measured that
how comfortable are you I had I made
this scale like visual analog scale and
asked them how comfortable do you feel
with this temperature and throughout the
study days during cold exposure and
thermal comfortable day that had a whole
day where I just kept them Thermal
comfortable to see do they activate the
brown fat if they're just completely
thermal comfortable as good as we could
get with that because you were asking
people
um on a scale from one to ten and five
being thermal comfortable where are you
on the scale so one would be very cold
and ten would be super burning hot
um yeah and so that was the way to like
try to figure out how do they actually
feel also during their studies they also
measured a Electro myography so of of
muscles to see do they shiver during the
cooling day and sometimes people shiver
before they know they're really
shivering so I had interesting yeah so
our conscious perception of shivering
might not be the best readout of shiver
yeah well you if you also get adapted to
the cold water you will have a less
shivering there will be less vigorous
they will be very small so you wouldn't
probably know that you are shivering
because this shivering is so small and
the mitochondria in the muscle cells
will be so dense that it doesn't need to
shiver maybe that much to get a dead
thermogenesis going and compared to when
you're completely new
uh to code water exposure you're not
adapted then the body needs to create
these mitochondria these energy Fabrics
to keep you warm and that's also what
the exercise is in the beginning but
um when we measured this we did see that
the winter swimmers were shivering less
or having less vigorous shivering when
they said I'm cold so even though they
they perception their perception of the
cup was pretty similar in in the in the
groups and we could see that the the
activation of the the muscles that we
measured on
um were different and more pictures in
the control group were the subjects
incentivized to be in the study were
they paid or anything of that sort of
they just happen to like doing uh cold
and sauna and so that's why they did the
study
um well they got paid a little bit for
it but not much and um that's how we do
this sure I was just curious yeah yeah I
was just curious there might be some
folks that Wonder so so what did you
discover in terms of changes in brown
fat insulin resistance or insulin
sensitivity rather and um metabolism so
what we we saw was we had this kind of
different measures to see what to try
and unreal what what's actually going on
when they are already adapted to the
cold water compared to a control group
who was matched on on various parameters
we we did see that the winter swimmers
had an increased insulin sensitivity
they produced less insulin on all the
experimental days so besides from just
cooling them and measuring the brown fat
on each of these cooling days or two
cooling days and one thermal comfortable
day right so I wanted to measure insulin
when I just they were fasting meaning
that they hadn't eaten in eight hours
before the study day
um and they were completely laying still
not moving just in a bit and we measured
insulin during the experimental day just
to see how what level are they on and we
could see that the the winter swimmer
had lower production of insulin and they
also when they had an glucose drink so
we give them that to see if they to test
before we enroll them in studies to see
if they have diabetes for example and
not knowing for example that that
wouldn't that would like ruin maybe the
study so we test for that and see if
they have like a normal curve so what
was this seeing that was that the winter
swimmers had a faster glucose clearance
in the bloodstream so after two hours we
could see that they had a lower level
and it went the curve went down faster
than in the control group so despite
having lower insulin release they have
better blood glucose clearance which is
really what you want what we all seek
right you know excessive insulin is bad
insulin being a um more or less a
chaperone for blood glucose
um can do all sorts of other things as
well of course but
um and having high blood glucose
obviously terrible yeah for cells
especially brain cells I don't think
people realize how toxic high blood
glucose is having high glucose if you
want to kill neurons you make you make
their uh put them in an environment
where there's too much sugar
um oh yeah very yeah very neurotoxic I
mean that's and their mechanisms like
insulin that buffer that we keep you
know keeping blood glucose in a
reasonable range so that
um that doesn't happen I mean I think
that's why people will go into
insulinemic shock
um hypoglycemic shock is also possible
so that range in which neurons are happy
is not a it's not a tremendously large
range incidentally the range in which
neurons are are
um happy in surviving uh is much greater
as one gets colder than when you heat up
I mean you can basically destroy brain
cells by getting too hot for too long oh
yeah yeah you can definitely destroy
brain cells permanently by getting too
cold for too long but you have to get
really really cold for a really long
time yeah yeah um very interesting yeah
we're thinking about doing uh an episode
on um uh sort of survival of the brain
after death kind of things which
actually happens you hear about these
people who are declared dead and then
come back and there's actually now a lot
of crowd preservation type approaches
for that this is uh anyway we risk going
into the the uh the esoteric now so I'll
steer us back to our discussion about
your study but
um so if I do the math
these subjects are in the cold let's say
they're doing three rounds of cold for
one to two minutes three to two or three
times a week
what were the thresholds that you
discovered were important for getting
these positive changes in um
such as reduced blood sugar or clearance
of blood sugar
um being more efficient uh reduced
insulin improved Brown fat distribution
and density
um how much cold exposure do people need
how much heat exposure do people need in
order to extract these benefits yeah so
when we then calculated the numbers
together we could see that this was
ended up being 11 minutes in total per
week so not in one session of course but
they had two to three visits to the
water and the sauna per week so when we
divide that out it corresponds to being
in cold water one to two minutes at a
time but also in the sauna 10 to 15
minutes at a time and I think this is
very like also similar to what we see in
other studies when we look for example
to the observational studies from The
Finnish cohort study from laauken at L
for example they published this very
amazing paper in 2015 and some results
from this long cohort study where they
show that that up to 30 minutes in the
sauna was healthy and they you you lower
your risk of cardiovascular disease and
that's like the threshold and if you go
further than that then there is not more
healthy benefits to to gain from that so
and before that it's like 19 minutes
then you will have this dose response
relationship up to 19 minutes that's
really in decreasing your risk of
cardiovascular diseases and I think
that's per week 90 minutes per week 90
minutes per session now recession yeah
per session if we
um
then compare that with my study which
was 10 to 15 minutes per session then I
think it fits very well with what we
call the Hermetic stress or healthy
stress that you expose the cells to this
kind of like potent very stressful
situation where they increase heat shock
proteins in the cells and that will
repair the cells but if you then overdo
it and you go beyond the maybe 30
minutes in the sauna this observational
study from Finland with more than up to
2 000 sauna bathers where they have full
of these for 20 years they see that a 30
minutes position is like enough and if
you go above that you don't get more
health benefits out of it so I think
there's a window where we can say the
healthy stress corresponds to like 10
minutes and I think it's per session per
session and it's not it's not much
actually so you don't need to
it shows that you don't have to expose
yourself very much to the Heat or very
much actually to the cold to get this
healthy benefits from going into cold
going to heat and have healthy benefits
on your cardiovascular system so I think
this is very important also a message to
to to get out that you don't have to go
extreme you don't have to swim for a
half an hour in the cold water you can
go in the water for one to two minutes
and per session but go up to 11 minutes
per week in total and for the sauna my
study showed uh 57 minutes in total two
weeks and if we also then divide it out
on these two to three days and two
sessions each day correspond to 10 to 15
minutes so it's a low threshold but I
think it's it's good to have that to
maybe we can aim for that if people need
to have something to to aim for and I
think and I think it's really good to
have that because then you you don't
have then you don't overdo it and if you
overdo it you exhaust the cells and that
will increase your risk of
cardiovascular disease also so well I
get a lot of questions about this and I
did solicit for questions for this
podcast on on Twitter and one of the
questions that I got was as one becomes
more cold adapted do the benefits start
to wear off or can people do too much
cold exposure of course the answer to
that is yes you can become hypothermic
but I'm sensing a different answer now
which is if I understand correctly the
threshold is 11 minutes total per week
of deliberate cold exposure divided into
two or three sessions of maybe one to
three minutes depending on how long
somebody stays in and then 57 minutes I
want to be careful not to round up um to
an hour but divided into maybe three
20-minute sessions or so you know um so
one doesn't have to be perfect as long
as you get a beyond that threshold but I
I wonder something which is
it the case that if somebody said oh you
know I'm just going to do one 11 minute
session per week that might actually not
be as beneficial as dividing it up
because what you told us earlier is that
the Hermetic response depends on having
that cold shock you actually don't want
to become too cold adapted I mean once
the blood pressure response drops down
so in minute four five and six yeah
you're getting very cold and you're
shivering but you're one is not getting
the autonomic stimulus that they want I
guess I could liken this to um if
exercise worked in a way where it was
only the first few minutes of exercise
that really triggered the adaptation of
course this is not how it works but um
in fact probably quite the opposite
um but if that were the case then it's
not simply the total amount of exercise
but dividing up the the the sessions
into little bouts where every single
time it acts as a stimulus that seems to
be the key here
um this is very important
um because having watched the landscape
of this on social media but also in
books and generally
um I think you're the first person to
really touch on this that the goal is
not to get so cold adapted that you can
sit in for the full 11 minutes in one
session where the goal isn't to be able
to do an hour of very hot sauna if you
want to I suppose people could do it for
other reasons but if the goal is to
improve these Health metrics yeah then
the idea is to keep the stimulus a
stimulus short exactly yeah great well
this also I think there's practical
feasibility as you pointed out because
getting into a cold shower or cold
immersion or natural body water for a
couple of minutes is far less uh
um you know challenging to most people
than finding a full morning to go you
know spend there
um but I've never really heard it
articulated that the longer sessions
might not be beneficial it might
actually be detrimental
um
that's very important uh were there any
other observations that you made
um that did not make it into the paper
or that were kind of in the the margin
notes I mean in terms of psychological
benefits
um or anything of that sort there was
this recent study on soldiers that
talked about weight loss it's sort of a
controversial study for a lot of reasons
um but one of the things they remarked
in the paper was that there were a lot
of psychological changes improved
buffering against anxiety
um they even the men and women in that
study reported one of the significant
effects was um significantly improved
sexual satisfaction of course they
didn't tell us what that meant for these
subjects but so we won't go there but
but a number of subjective improvements
was there anything that you observed or
took note of in in your study that
perhaps didn't make the main abstract
but that we should be aware of uh
yeah there was some um and I'm I'm today
I regret that I didn't measure on sleep
for example I I frankly didn't really
think about that when I I when I
designed the study
um so we were very
um much occupied with the metabolism and
kind of had the thought maybe this could
impact a Sleep Quality
um and I wish I just if I had the
thought that why don't you just ask them
in a questionnaire but I asked them
every morning or everyone who's not many
Monies to just two mornings actually and
we measured on
um but the winter swimmers
um
told us before I wrote them that they
had a really good sleep quality the
control group also had that but they
told me on the day where we measured the
brown fat on a day and night so if
actually two days and two nights and
they told me that they didn't they had a
good night's sleep but they also woke up
so it's just telling me that they also
had like a quick wake up and then they
fell asleep again
um and the winter swimmers is so they
have a really good sleep so it's like
and in general they also say we we sleep
very well I sleep very well so it's
anecdotally General it corresponds to
what I heard in my study but nothing
that I measured on
um which would could be fun to do in the
future but we didn't measure on Sleep
Quality that would have been a really
good idea to do they also told me that
they were very comfortable when they
were cold they they don't mind a winter
swimmers they don't mind going out for
example
um in in the code with a t-shirt they
were also less scared of showing their
skin that was also one observation
interesting yeah so kind of a reduced
social anxiety yeah they were just so
comfortable in the lab you as you just
mentioned before coats on and
everybody's journeying around us very
busy and and all the other scientists
out in the hallway and also my
supervisor I had her office down down
the hallway and and one of the winter
swimmers one day it just got out of bed
after I had been in the study for eight
hours we it was a long day right he
jumped out of the bed and had his
clothes in the bathroom and he went out
completely naked he didn't care he just
went out it was like so that's a side
effect perhaps of getting too
comfortable with the cold
um and we're not recommending that
although in your book you
um did a uh you dedicated some let me
start that again although in your book
you dedicated some uh pages to
um naked winter swimming or I should say
naked cold water exposure as opposed to
um uh with bathing suit yeah are there
any data on this I'm sorry chuckling but
um I think in most places in the United
States it's uh skinny dipping is not um
is not legal most public beaches there
are a few in fact where my laboratory
before moving to Stanford was in San
Diego and I at the Salk Institute for
biological studies beautiful building
incredible Sciences done there the beach
right below that is called Black's Beach
okay and um and it's a known nude beach
um and so whenever tourists were heading
down the stairway there
um I would you know sort of let them
know especially if they had kids I'd let
them know you know and it's a nude beach
of a particular
um uh of a particular genre so I I'd
give them a little warning about what
what they could expect down below it's a
um in any event those beaches are quite
rare
um in the United States maybe compared
to Europe I don't know
um but yeah maybe yeah so is there
anything special about
um clothes lists versus closed um
exposure yeah I think in that sense we
have a bit more free with this kind of
like but but remember we also had this
winter swimming culture for so for
hundreds of years in Denmark and the
wind said the oldest winter swimming
clubs that we have especially the one we
have in Copenhagen where I did my next
study which we haven't talked about but
and it's also not published yet but
um in that winter swimming club it's the
oldest one we have and it's huge and
they they swim naked at this facility
men and women men and women and they
have sauna where they can go in together
and they also have the separate saunas
but it's very much a Danish thing and
and I think it's I think it's I think
it's good if people want that
um and I had it in my book because
people want to know if they have to swim
with their bathing suit on or if they
can take it off or what's the what's the
difference is there any difference in
this and if you ask me there is no
difference oh if you have your little
skinny bikini on it's not going to do
any difference to your cold exposure or
your adaptation it's not going to do any
difference for your benefits of course
but I think that it has something else
it has something to do with how you also
observe yourself how you absorb your
surroundings and it's sometimes some
sense of freedom in skinny dipping so I
think people in Denmark who does this is
they do the winter swimming because they
feel free when they do they come home
from work they go to this club and they
skinny dip and they feel like in touch
with nature and they have maybe done
this their whole life so this is an old
tradition in Denmark in some of the
clubs
um but the newer clubs are coming they
don't they don't do skinny diff so
everyone has bathing suit I never Skinny
Dip because there are people around
people with phones and taking pictures
all the time so this is different
different nowadays everything's recorded
yeah yeah and also this this old
tradition is also fading away because of
that yeah I um I use sauna and cold at
home but when I travel there there's a
Banya so Russian Banya has hot sauna and
cold plunge um there's one in San
Francisco called Archimedes Banya
um and that one is clothing optional so
some people are clothed such as myself
and then other people are not and it's
co-ed
most of the time I think they have male
female separated uh evenings or
something like that and then
um the other Banya is Spa 88 which is in
on Wall Street in New York is an amazing
Banya as well and these are starting to
crop up in different cities or maybe
they've been there for a long time and
has deliberate cold exposure and sauna
gets more popular more people are using
them the the one in New York that I that
Spa 88 is always closed
um and it's interesting because you know
people hear naked or skinny dipping and
they they might get certain ideas in
mind it
um yeah all these places are very well
lit and they all have a tone of kind of
um of Health that it's about the kind of
health and and wellness
um I guess the point being that
um there's no requirement uh to do one
thing or the other although in the
studies that uh you did obviously um
people were clothed but I I did um
I did pay attention to those pages in
your book I thought it was interesting
that you put some um some dedicated uh
passages in your book related to this
and I think my publisher wanted that
yeah it was not me it was like my
publisher really wanted to have a little
discussion about that so I was like okay
well I think it you know it points to a
larger theme which is I think for a lot
of people who already do these practices
um there's no shock there yeah um for
people that do not do deliberate cold
exposure or sauna I think that
um you know there is this idea perhaps
that oh you know these are
um Traditions that are are kind of
Fringe or that they're kind of and I
just I want to um cue that point because
there's so many things that are
happening right now in biomedical
research and Medicine you know serious
quality peer-reviewed studies published
in excellent journals like your paper on
things like deliberate cold exposure
sauna
um the use of particular supplements
natural natural herbs and supplements I
mean there's an entire brain answer the
National Institutes of Health in the
United States dedicated just to the
study of supplements and behavioral
interventions for health like meditation
and breath work really incredible it's
really incredible and psychedelics of
course being something that for a long
time was part of a certain community and
feel and now is being um frankly adopted
by mainstream medicine even Pharma so it
the the times are changing
um and so uh yes I think it's important
to know that um it's perfectly
acceptable and encouraged to wear
clothing absolutely absolutely yeah
yeah and one other thing that I wanted
to to mention going back to your
questions around with there were any
observations in the studies which would
really maybe haven't discussed yet and
maybe it's in in the back of the the
paper and not mentioned that much was
one of the winter swimmers didn't have
any brown fat when we measured him zero
zero and uh in we do see this um in in
in previous studies as well that some
humans don't have any brown fat was he
did he carry a lot of white fat adipose
tissue was he was he obese no he wasn't
no he was not obese because that he
would not have been in the study then oh
right yes you mentioned this earlier
forgive me no no it's fine but he was um
but what I did observe before I knew
that he didn't have any problem for us
that during the cooling experiment where
I cooled them for uh two hours before
they go into the Pet City scanner
he
was not able to control his shivering
like the winter swimmers they could
so he got he got very cold very easily
uh compared to the others so and without
I didn't know what was different about
him but we could all or me and the three
others were working on the experiment we
were like okay what's going on because
we turned down the the temperature but
he started like shivering and then we
had to turn it up again and it was just
all over the place the temperature is
not it wasn't that controlled like the
others it was pretty similar protocol I
could just do pretty much the same
because they were same size and they
also same gender so it it was easier to
like foresee what was going to happen
and when will they start Shiver I
quickly learned that but with this
subject it was just with this volunteer
was just very much different and then
when we scanned him and didn't find any
problem I I I didn't even think about it
so when we scanned him we didn't see
anything I told the Pet City people to
like oh you put up the wrong uh scanning
explain the technology yeah the
technology it was like this scanning
looked like the thermal neutral day the
thermal comfortable day where we also
scanned them to see if they have any
brown fat so you have made a mistake I
was pretty sure and the re-analysis and
analyzed this um
scanning and they just concluded well it
the scanning was fine the experiment
went well it was just that he didn't
have any brown fat so he was like but we
just in the paper called a brown fat
negative so he didn't have any and in in
my studies it would be called a knockout
so it didn't have any brown fan so what
the observation with him and I think
that would be that's interesting is that
he both
shivered very early on and didn't
regulate his temperature as well he also
told me that then he was like F5 on the
scale of how comfortable he felt with
the cold
um
so it was from one to ten and five being
thermal comfortable and 10 being very
cold and and one very hard so on this
like scale up and up and down
and he he was like more up and down on
this scale than any of the others it was
an observation that I did
um
what we did see in his blood samples
also that his blood samples looked a bit
more like the control group
um also his insulin levels were like the
control group so a little bit higher
than the other winter swimmers and he
also had
um
his blood glucose clearance was not as
fast as
um as the the other winter swimmers so
he was like an outlier what we call it
an in the analysis we also had to take
him out of the analysis because he was
an outlier
um so the results showing that the brown
fat
is a more efficiently activated in the
winter swimmers is without him having
him in that group but it didn't ruin the
study if we I tried to put him in as
well and didn't it didn't ruin the
results or anything but just to to keep
it more clear we put we took him out of
the analysis yeah so he was a mutant a
knockout yeah and I'm sure they're out
there um very interesting so if you
shiver early
um then perhaps you have less brown fat
to begin with although it's hard to
conclude from one person that's sort of
the the the implication there oh you
haven't adapted to the code so you
should build that up yeah right so in
addition to looking at regulation of
blood sugar
Brown fat
metabolism and so on were there any
markers that you examined in the
deliberate cold exposure group as
compared to controls that reveal to you
that deliberate cold exposure could have
additional benefits
um say for uh immune system function or
for any function for that matter
before we looked at inflammation of
course we measure of the outcome of
blood pressure and so on but we also
measured the il-6 in the study just to
see also an inflammatory
anti-inflammatory marker so il-6 went up
and it also follows with the il-10 so
that is like also very known in the
literature so we measured that and I
think it's very important to to think
about the code exposure the heat
exposure as something that then lowers
the inflammation in the body and if we
can do that we will have an open door
for
um a preventing lifestyle diseases right
so for
um type 2 diabetes but actually also for
some mental diseases as well so as known
as depression and anxiety and also
Alzheimer's disease which are all
associated in research also newer
research showing that a that
inflammation increases the risk of
depression anxiety and Alzheimer's
neurological diseases so if we can
decrease inflammation in the body we
will decrease our modern lifestyle
diseases but also these increasing
mental diseases that we see in these
modern lifestyle times
um so I think that
it's I think it's very interesting that
we can go out in nature and we can use
these natural stressors and it I don't
want to have it sound very romantic or
anything it's just it's just exposure to
temperature actually just a colder to
heat that is going to trick our body
into a natural state again and reset it
where the the homeostasis the balance
has is lost a bit so the body is going
to repair itself in that way and I think
it's beautiful that we can do that just
by changing the temperature of our body
and although people are very scared of
doing this because in our times we have
been away from cold away from Heat
temperature for some for decades now
um since we isolated our houses better
and we are more sedentary we also sit
more indoor we don't move as much so
this very modern sedentary lifestyle has
made us more temperature comfortable
just neutral so no no wonder I mean that
obesity is increasing we don't expose
ourselves to the Natural stresses that
we did earlier on
um in in our environment but also about
so maybe the 70s the 60s where we
started having more like comfortable
Lifestyles right and obesity increases
in the in the 80s we can see that from
statistics so I think that if we can
take in cold and heat and you mentioned
other things also before but of course
exercise is very important here and also
a bit of fasting actually because it all
increases the Hermetic stress in the
body so it's it doesn't have to be other
than natural stresses to the body which
then could keep us in that Natural
Balance again could we talk about what I
refer to as the soberg principle which
is to end on cold and the reason I
called it the sober principle is because
um in reviewing oh by the way I wasn't a
official reviewer of your paper but I
mean in reading and um reviewing your
paper for its after published Contents I
noticed that you had people end on cold
and this has been a long-standing debate
in the the uh deliberate cold exposure
Community should you warm up with a warm
shower afterwards or get back in the
sauna what should you end on cold or end
on Heat and the sober principle says end
on cold as I understand it
in order to force your body to heat
itself back up and thereby increase
metabolism further still is that right
yes so when you when you end on the cold
you you force your body to heat up by
itself and that will require that you
activate you keep your brown fat
activated and also your muscles which is
a good thing it's a good collaboration
so keep your thermogenesis up and that's
like an an exercise even when you go
home so in that way you don't have to
think about your cold exposure or
dipping in in your plunge or open sea or
what it is as just a an exercise that
you do for one to two minutes and then
it's over if you end on the code you
have an exercise for your body going on
for hours afterwards and that's not only
on your metabolism but it's also going
to keep your neurotransmitters activated
as well and increase that because your
body is still cold so you need that
those neurotransmitters to activate the
brown fat as well so that's going to
make your brown fat cells more efficient
and also your muscle cells more
efficient so increasing mitochondria in
the cells which will then generate heat
very fast so if you have done this for a
few times so maybe three four five times
um
being new to this but I have tried it a
few times you will notice a switch where
you like feel that you get easily warmer
and you can keep yourself warmer and
that is also what was shown in in my
study is that the the winter swimmers
were physically warmer on the skin
compared to the control group so they
when they are out of the cold when
they're out of the cold just relaxing
and we tested this in in on the days
where they were sleeping in the lab so
we could see that they had a more
activation of the brown fat a higher
temperature so probably because they
also lose heat they have a high heat
loss to the body compared to the control
group
um because they have a more vascular
skin because of the contrast or cold and
heat so they lose heat faster from the
body during that day but is that a bad
thing no probably not because that's
gonna keep your brown fat and your
muscles a little bit activated so we you
will have to to it it has to work to
keep you warm I and I would hypothesize
that it also might lead to some of the
um subjectively reported improvements in
sleep because in order to fall asleep
you need your core body temperature to
drop by about one to three degrees so
it's not just sufficient to be sleeping
in a cold room and under the blanket you
also need your body temperature to drop
yes and so what you're saying if I
understand correctly is that by forcing
by ending on cold and forcing oneself to
heat up naturally that increases the
brown fat stores which I sort of see as
a kind of like the oil in the candle of
the Furnace that is thermogenesis
and that
in turn leads to increased heat loss
which people might think oh I don't want
to lose heat from the body but there are
times when you want to lose heat from
the body basically it sounds like what
we want is to be a very efficient
heating and cooling system yes that it's
not about being cold or being hot it's
really about keeping the system tuned
well keeping the oil in the candle this
brown fat
um functioning yeah what could I ask one
question about
um fed or fasted is there any or rather
are there any known benefits of doing
deliberate cold exposure and or sauna
fasted uh versus
um after a meal say within the last hour
or something of that sort I do my
deliberate cold exposure first thing in
the morning
um so in general I'm fasted because I
don't eat until a little bit later in
the day yeah uh but what's known about
that and was that looked at in your
study I know you measured glucose but
that was as a separate
um test away from the cold away from the
cold yeah but I also tested glucose on
the days under cold so we measured that
as well on on the cooling days
um
specifically on fasting and fat I don't
know I don't think that I've seen
studies specifically on this okay
um more science needed um
a number of people ask about the use of
deliberate cold exposure to offset some
of the symptoms of various diseases now
here we're not talking about curing
disease we're talking about offsetting
symptoms
um one question I've seen quite often is
whether or not people with Raynaud's
syndrome this is a syndrome and my high
school girlfriend had this syndrome and
I'll never forget uh we went we're at a
school dance together and um this was
when we first started dating and um she
had Ray nodes which leads to very poor
blood flow to the the uh the extremities
and
um and she was very cold so she left to
go to the bathroom and warm up her hands
in the warm water and I was left
standing there at the dance and people
came up to me and asked you know why I
was there and who I was there with and I
kept telling them who I was with and
they didn't believe me because they
couldn't believe that she would be with
me made total sense if you knew me at
the time
um I was I I was way out of my league
with her um at the time I like to think
eventually I caught up but in any case
um she was in the bathroom for about an
hour so at one point I did consider the
possibility that she had just left but
indeed she hadn't she warmed her hands
back up but people with Ray nodes suffer
from this
um from this thing a very very cold
extremities
um their fingertips will even turn blue
um you know as if they were starting to
get frostbitten it's quite dramatic
um and that question gets asked whether
or not there's any use of cold to try
and increase the um elasticity the
plasticity of the of the small
capillaries and vessels by everything
you've described up until now it seems
like that would be a logical thing to do
um and in addition to that whether or
not people with autoimmune conditions
people with
um any other types of conditions are
known to benefit from deliberate cold
exposure I'm not aware of any studies
but I get asked about this a lot and
there were a lot of questions about this
for you in the Twitter feed yeah I think
[Music]
I haven't seen any studies directed on
this outcome and measuring rhinoids
syndrome
um I do know that it's it's uh it's not
that rare actually a problem and I know
that many women or more women than men
suffer from this
um but logically it would help them if
they expose their hands to cold and also
heat to make the vest it more vascular
but
and I have heard from people saying that
it had helped them but also heard for
some others saying it didn't help them
so studies are needed on this specific
topic I think
I hurt my hands when I go into the cover
and I don't have this syndrome at all
but I keep my hands above the water you
do yeah and I do that um often I take a
little bit of a swim and then of course
I have to have my hands in the water but
it helps me when I then get back to the
daddy and then take my hands up because
then I can stand there for a little bit
and get my one to two minutes exposure
and then I can go up because then
otherwise that would stop me from being
in the water enough time that I as long
as I I would like to so if people suffer
from having this pain in the fingers and
it can be very intense so just take the
hands up a bit from the water and and
that's gonna help you also boots
neoprene boots it's going to help on the
feet some people have the hurt and feel
the pain in the feet and on the ankles
and that's going to help them also a
little bit okay so there is no problem
with keeping hands out or feet in uh
neoprene booties if people feel the need
to do that if that's what the if pain of
the hands or feet is a barrier for
people doing uh cold exposure then it
seems it would be okay to do to keep
hands out or to keep your feet Yes
because then you you do get the exposure
uh but of course hands and feet are very
potent places in your body to get a fast
activation of your nervous system of
course but if you can just you can also
just dip them and then take them up it's
gonna still gonna activate that but you
have your full body is covered in in the
co-preceptors you'll have a full
activation anyways so you are providing
very reassuring information to people
because I know a number of people that
do not like to put their hands in I find
that the more of my body I get in the
more comfortable I am it's like I don't
know if it's psychologically and or
physiologically I find that if where
there's an interface between the water
and the cold it's most uncomfortable so
I prefer to just get everything under I
keep my head out although I these days
I've been dunking all the way in and
then coming out and then dunking once
more with my head under before I get out
after the the plunge
um that raises a different question now
we're getting into kind of the
practicalities of deliberate cold
exposure which I think are important
um sometimes I'll experience and I hear
from a lot of people that they'll get a
kind of back of the head headache at the
interface of the of the water
um you know when they're in doing cold
immersion to the neck
um okay I assume this has to do with
blood flow that there's vasoconstriction
right up until the neck and in the
region surrounding it but that maybe
there's still blood flow to the head but
do we know what the origin of these um
headaches is and again this doesn't
happen for everybody but some people do
experience them okay yeah I haven't
really heard about that one specifically
um so but I would say that there are
different reasons for maybe keeping your
head out of the water but it seems like
maybe for some that could be a reason
for like just getting like a quick head
dunk going all the way in yeah that's
what I've started doing to eliminate I
wasn't getting headaches but I could I
noticed that interface okay and I wasn't
in the rest of the experience at
somewhat experience of it so much so I
started dunking all the way in I noticed
in some of the photos that you've put
out
um and in your book that you'll
sometimes wear a cap while you go in
yeah okay and well it comes from uh
different reasons uh so let's talk about
some of the physiological reasons so
when you submerged in in cold water up
to the neck and study have shown and
this is from Denmark studies from Peace
hospital
um that when you submerge into cold
water up to the neck at zero degrees uh
so zero degrees Celsius very cold and
you have a decreased blood flow to the
brain by around 30 to 40 percent and
makes sense because you activate the SIM
pathetic nervous system and and
therefore you will have a less blood
flow to the brain makes you maybe a
little bit dizzier and proof again that
you're you need a heart more than a
brain because when the sympathetic
nervous system gets activated uh blood
flow is maintained to the heart to keep
you alive but obviously taken away from
the brain to keep you from thinking
that's why it's hard to think when
you're stressed yeah well the muscles
and then your vital organs need to you
have to be able to run away from that
tiger right the rationale of its total
sense and who am I to disagree with
Mother Nature
well but yeah so one of the reasons
being that you should keep your head out
of the water is that you could increase
that decrease in blood flow to the brain
further if you dump the head so there's
just a very nice paper from um from a a
research group in Canada where they have
collectively looked at different papers
where they compared heat loss in a group
in the papers where they dunk the head
and compared to heat loss uh submerging
up to the neck to see how much extra
heat do we lose from our core when we
dump the head so and I think it's very
interesting that if you submerge up to
the neck you have a heat loss of 11 from
the body core
and when you then also dunk the head you
will increase that heat loss rate by 36
percent
so that means I'm not saying that I'm
not I'm not here to say what is right
and what is wrong I just think that
people should know the information so
they can for themselves evaluate what is
best for them but if you increase your
heat loss rate by 36 from your core
that's going to increase your after drop
which we touched upon a little bit
earlier even further so that's meaning
that you are closer to hypothermia than
you are if you just submerge up to the
neck so you should really think about
whether this is like something that you
want to do or if it's just better for
you not to get that code in your core
the beanie is also because I have a
little bit of sensitive ears so meaning
that if there's wind and because we swim
in the open sea in Denmark we have a lot
of wind our when our conditions are just
very rainy very windy and when the
temperature is also freezing you could
get this what is that called um so very
cold and light-headed just from wind so
if you also submerge into cold water and
you then get up you could you will get a
brain freeze immediately so it is enough
to just go up to the neck wherever you
need to just not get dizzy also because
the the heat loss is increased of course
but also the blood flow to the brain has
decreased so the beanie will keep you a
little bit warmer so you can stay for
one to two minutes so it's just a way of
like getting around some of the
conditions also so people can choose
that if they they feel that but it's
quite normal to do in in Scandinavia
whereabini love it and um so for those
of you afraid of doing a two-minute cold
shower what uh Dr Silver just described
uh let's uh you see how um she and
others are capable of doing things far
harder than that
um when the way you describe it with the
cold wind and Scandinavia and uh
um is is quite striking along the lines
of covering the head um there's this um
seemingly paradoxical
thing of people going into hot saunas
and wearing wool caps you know if you go
to a Banya or you I go to a sauna and
there are people who are
um well from Eastern Europe or typically
or Finland or
um Russia or Ukraine or elsewhere what
you'll see is that many of them are
wearing wool caps in the sauna which
many people think is to make it hotter
that's actually not the case it actually
insulates you from the heat environment
the urge the sense of urgency to get out
of the hot sauna is a brain-driven
mechanism and so um the reason that
people wear wool hats in the saunas it
actually lets you stay in the sauna
longer because it takes a lot of heat to
the skin before you feel that you you
half to get out whereas so when you
insulate the brain you don't get that
signal it's pretty interesting I've
tried this before just by putting a
towel over my head in the sauna and you
can stay in there you know much more
easily and for for much longer
you know as we talk about these
different stimuli for um the Hermetic
response the adaptation of distress you
know it occurs to me that the the big
ones in our evolutionary history have
been light
right I mean you were talking about
seasonal changes
um we know there especially as you go up
to Nordic countries there are seasonal
changes in the amount of Light by time
of year dramatic ones in fact less so at
the equator of course yeah um light
temperature
food movement and it it's sort of
interesting and at the same time perhaps
it should have been obvious to us that
there are stimuli that our bodies have
evolved to adapt to in very powerful
ways and so the idea that temperature
heat and cold could evoke these
tremendous physiological changes that
are beneficial for us probably shouldn't
surprise us at all I mean I mean this is
why we I mean these are not
um esoteric mechanisms they're actually
the the foundational mechanisms by which
our our body and the bodies of other
animals adapt
um so I do have a question about the uh
different ways that people could
approach deliberate cold exposure so for
instance
um
children I've been to banyas where there
are kids you know six or seven years old
with their parents at the Banya
um and so they're in hot sauna I'm not
suggesting people do this if they're if
they're not you know adapted to it and
you know talk to your parents kids and
talk to your kids parents um talk to
your doctors
um but is remarkable I mean uh children
doing sauna from a young age or
deliberate cold exposure uh are there
any data on this and is it safe assuming
that you know obviously that they can
swim and they're doing this in a tub or
shower
um and then I'd also like to ask you
about are there any additional male
female differences I know your study
focused on men but um other Studies have
focused on both and you of course
um are a woman and can attest to your
own experience with this
um so children men women
um differences there in terms of
protocols is there anything that people
should build into the structure of of
their deliberate cold exposure that's
unique to that
so yeah so this was on cold exposure so
um yeah I think that
um starting with the the question about
children
um I think that it's important to
to think about as children are smaller
than adults so we cannot really
completely transfer all the information
and the benefits and also protocols for
how long and and stuff like that two
children we cannot do that because they
are just smaller in mass and one study
that actually
um improves this is a study where they
have compared a heat loss in children
boys who were 12 years old compared to
adults men and looked at the heat loss
of the cold temperature
and expose them to a one or one or two
minutes
um code exposure immersion up to the
neck and what they saw was that the the
boys in this study could actually defend
the core temperature in a same way as
the adults could but they had to use
their muscles way faster so it means
that they couldn't stay for as long and
they used more energy to defend their
core temperature compared to the to the
adults but for one minute it seems that
they could actually complain but they
would be colder when they then come out
because they are smaller in their Mass
to that ratio right so it means that if
the surface is so large on children and
their mass and muscles being smaller to
that ratio it means that they can be in
the water
less time before they get hypothermic so
just think about that they are just
smaller they can't defend their
temperature for a very long time but in
this study they saw that for up to I
think it was a minute or so they can one
minute yeah I'm glad you mentioned
hypothermia and smaller bodied
um people children uh I used to do some
Pacific ocean swims in the morning
um without wetsuits and I adapted to it
pretty quickly and these are fairly long
swims and we brought an excellent
swimmer with us
um that was interning with me for a
while
um is 16 years old at the time and very
lean and um it wasn't small for his age
but he was smaller than us than the it
was all guys on the swim that day
Sometimes women join us
um and he got hypothermic
and he's an excellent swimmer and he
didn't report feeling overly cold but um
fortunately we got him to Shore and
heated him up again
um so he lived I don't think his mother
was going to ever let him go swimming
with us again he's thriving in the world
he's a university student now
um and he recalls that swim I mean this
is why you always want to Ocean swim
with a buddy with people
um yeah he he became hypothermic his
teeth turned yellow he was slurring his
words he wasn't making sense you know we
got him on the shore and he was kind of
you know drooling and a little
semi-euphoric and then kind of you know
it was
um hypothermia is no joke so I think
yeah so I I I'm really glad that this is
coming up because the cold is a powerful
stimulus and um and I and kids are at a
and smaller bodied people are at a
greater risk of hypothermia so a good
reason to approach it with caution maybe
start with cold showers get uh then cold
immersion and still water natural water
and open bodies of water of course are
always going to be
um more dangerous for other reasons
currents and things of that sort of
exactly okay I'm drowning yeah so
important note there
um what about any additional male female
differences or similarities that um we
should be aware of and this comes up all
the time on social media anytime I post
anything about a study it's what about
women because oftentimes there are
differences yeah yeah and and there are
we we also just took about the
difference in in in temperature in men
and women so it means that if we did if
we replicated my study in women it could
be that they would have enough you can
say cold exposure with just nine minutes
per week it could be because they
apparently are also just colder and and
they have increased metabolism in their
Brown fat is just they have more Brown
fat it could be but this is just
something that I I frankly don't know
but women also do cold exposure winter
swimming with the 11 minutes protocol I
do it myself and feel good about it so I
would say that
um women Also regarding activation of
the brown fat it should be the same
um in theory but I don't know if women
actually
do you need to have another protocol
when it comes to this rapid code
exposure I think that it's another
question if we are talking about ice
swimming when it comes to how far can
you be in the cold water without getting
hypothermic then there will be
differences in men and and female but
but if you do this cold exposure for a
very brief amount of time which is what
I try to to talk to about talk about
what we call also micro stressing the
body to to increase the Hermetic stress
the healthy stress then this is such a
short amount of
um exposure that it it's fairly the same
I think I think women can look at this
as a fairly a good protocol for the for
for them as well I always say that if
you really dread the cold and um and
don't like the cold then you are a
perfect candidate for using deliberate
cold exposure because the sympathetic
aka the stress response will be greater
and thereby the adaptation to that
shorter one or two minutes is
um is going to be much greater right for
people that are perfectly comfortable in
the cold it's harder to get an
adaptation response the same way that if
somebody's very strong and they can lift
a very heavy weight that that very heavy
weight is unlikely to evoke the same
kind of or same degree of of uh adaptive
responses if somebody is not quite as
strong so another reason to keep these
exposures relatively short yeah and more
frequent than to do longer duration
exposures frequently however let's say
somebody only had two days a week
um to do deliberate cold exposure maybe
they don't have access to Asana maybe
they do would you suggest that they get
in for one or two minutes then get out
then get back in for another couple of
minutes then get out and call that for
you know four or five minutes
um to try and get to that 11 minutes
total per week
um as opposed to getting in for a full
five minutes
um and then getting out and coming back
a second time that week I know this is
getting down into the weeds but these
are the sorts of things that I think
people really want to know because a lot
of people either don't live close to a
body of water or don't have a cold
plunge
um that they can do this with although
cold shower apparently works too so most
people live close to a shower yeah it's
a definite I think the the changes in
temperature is what is
strengthening your your cells in the
body so if you can do the short amount
of exposure and then get out and get
back in that is gonna you can say um
strengthen yourselves because you are
challenging them to to adapt to
um changing temperatures so doing one
session you can change this right you
you can do it if you are able to go to
cold water but also a sauna then you
just do it that automatically you will
have a change in temperature but you
could also do it by variating the
temperature in your coat plunge if you
have
if you have a plunge or if you have an
open CEO or you have seasoning Seasons
even you have we have that in Denmark so
we have four seasons and the temperature
is going to vary with that so we have
nature who can just change this for us
and we don't have to think about it if
you have a cold plunge well then I would
say that changing the temperature is
what is going to create this hermetic
stress and also keep your cells on its
toes you can say because you are tried
the body will still be um stressed to
try to adapt to the new temperature as
it's seen as something actually toxic to
the body right it's a small small piece
of toxicity that you are exposing
yourself to
we don't have to swallow it but it's
enough that you touch it actually yeah
great a great way to frame it
um
that brings me back to this idea of
circadian time in your study you didn't
um control first specific time of day
and now I'm realizing that may be a
great asset to the whole thing so we
know for instance that our bodies go
through pretty dramatic shifts in
temperature from the time we wake up
um our body starts heating up as we wake
up and continues to heat until the
afternoon and then starts to drop in the
later afternoon and then assuming all
things are working correctly
um that body temperature drops and we
sleep so I could imagine that doing
deliberate cold exposure at different
times just by way of convenience or by
way of intention could be very
beneficial because my body temperature
is going to be quite a bit warmer at one
time of day versus another and in that
way keeping the system tuned and that's
really what I keep hearing coming
through in as you explain these data and
all these beautiful studies yours and
others is that it's not really about
getting cold it's about going from warm
to cold and from cold to warm it's not
it and I love this idea because I I
probably said this a hundred times on my
podcast and a million times in my life
and I'll continue to which is that
biology is not an event it's a process
like these these um metabolic and
thermoregulatory processes are indeed
like the Turning of a knob it's a verb
as opposed to a noun and I and so I I
think if people can internalize that
idea that they're going to have a lot
more flexibility a lot more fun and and
get a lot more benefit as opposed to
thinking okay I need to get into X
degrees of water for x amount of time on
X number of days yeah you know
all the time how much and how cold and
and I mean it's not it's just like well
because we also don't have studies
showing exactly if you just keep five
degrees in your water and you do that
for a month then what happens we maybe
the future will know much more about
this and I'm sure it's going to come and
I really hope so but I just think by
logically changing that temperature up
and down up and down and you also do
that in your water it doesn't really
it's not that important what temperature
you you will have your water then then
just keep changing it going up and down
it could be all up to 12 degrees Celsius
you're going to activate your brown fat
anyways I mean 12 19 degrees a cold air
is enough to activate your rampers so
maybe we don't have to go as cold as I
think many people think
um and putting ice even all the time it
you don't have to it's not I don't think
it's necessary to to expose yourself to
that cold temperature all the time
um but vary it a bit so keep the system
off balance and that's the way to keep
it tuned Yeah you mentioned a study that
is more recent or an ongoing that's not
published or um if you're willing um
could you share maybe some of the data
from that our findings from that study
um with of course the the cue to
everybody that these are not yet
published data so the conclusions could
change the data could change for that
matter yeah so we have we haven't
analyzed all the data yet and I I know
from the study that we did publish that
we we would need to look more of the
data so I don't really have any results
yet that I can share because we are
still in very preliminary analysis of
this so I I wouldn't know yet what to
exactly say about it but what we looked
at was both men and women method so
that's that's coming oh that's fantastic
that answer is going to please a great
number of people and and Intrigue
everybody so
well listen I I want to really thank you
for coming here today to talk about your
work
um and the incredible direction that it
points to because I think that
um you know no one study is definitive
but your study really again stands as a
landmark in the landscape of exploring
deliberate cold exposure and Heat
how it can impact and potentially impact
our health because
frankly there just haven't been that
many
um high resolution uh detailed modern
studies of this there have been studies
of sauna there have been some studies of
coal there are a lot of groups in
physiology that work on hypothermia and
very cold exposure but um most of the
temperatures used in those days just
aren't practical so first of all I just
want to thank you for doing the work
that you've done and for the work that
you continue to do I'm
um uh waiting with baited breath as they
say to um to hear the results of this
study that's ongoing on both men and
women so um we'll have to have you back
to inform us about that soon and I want
to thank you for
um the incredible public education
efforts that you've been doing on social
media
um and in with respect to your book
um and we of course will put links to
all of those things in the show note
captions so people can learn from you
and can continue to learn from you we we
certainly need more scientists who are
both experienced with doing hardcore
research as it's called and who also do
the practices I think that's a wonderful
additional asset you know you're not
just behind a lab coat or bundled up in
a down uh in a down feather jacket as
everyone else is getting in the cold you
do these things and that you are so open
and generous in the way that you share
uh knowledge which includes coming here
today to to share knowledge with me and
uh our audience so thank you ever so
much you're very welcome I am so pleased
to be here and thank you so much for
inviting me and I could explain my study
and I can share some of my insights from
from doing that so I'm very grateful for
being here
delighted and we'll have to have you
back again thank you for joining me for
today's discussion all about deliberate
cold and deliberate heat exposure
science and protocols with Dr Susanna
soberg if you'd like to learn more about
Dr soberg's research or you would like
to learn about the research of her
Institute The soberg Institute please
see the links in the show note caption
also in the show note caption you can
find a link to Dr sober's excellent book
winter swimming if you're learning from
and or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel that's
a terrific zero cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on Spotify and apple and in
addition on both Spotify and apple you
can leave us up to a five-star review if
you have questions for me or topics
you'd like me to cover on the huberman
Lab podcast or guests that you'd like me
to consider inviting on the huberman Lab
podcast please put that in the comments
on YouTube I do read all the comments in
addition please check out the sponsors
mentioned the beginning and throughout
today's episode that's the best way to
support this podcast not so much on
today's episode but on various previous
episodes of the huberman live podcast we
discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for things like enhancing sleep
focus and hormone support the huberman
Lab podcast is proud to have partnered
with momentous supplements if you'd like
to hear more about the supplements
discussed on the huberman Lab podcast
please go to live momentous
spelledous.com slash huberman again
that's livemomentis.com huberman if
you're not already following the
huberman Lab podcast on social media we
are huberman lab on Instagram Twitter
Facebook and Linkedin and on all those
places I focus on material that somewhat
overlaps with content from the huberman
Lab podcast but often is distinct from
the content covered on the huberman Lab
podcast so again it's huberman lab on
all social media channels for those of
you that haven't already subscribed to
our so-called neural network newsletter
this is a completely zero cost monthly
newsletter that has summaries of podcast
episodes and so-called tool kits
toolkits are lists of about a page to
two pages long that give the critical
tools for instance for optimizing sleep
for neuroplasticity or deliberate cold
exposure or deliberate heat exposure
optimizing dopamine again all available
to you at zero cost you simply go to
hubermanlab.com go to the menu tab in
the corner scroll down to newsletter you
provide us your email we do not share
your email with anybody and in addition
to that there are samples of toolkits on
the hubermanlab.com website again under
newsletter and you don't even have to
sign up to access those but I think most
people do end up signing up for the
newsletter because it's rich with useful
information and again completely zero
cost thank you once again for joining me
for today's discussion with Dr Susanna
soberg and last but certainly not least
thank you for your interest in science
[Music]